foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen to the 2021 v-day
Worlds Cup
we are in the midst of the finals today
is the long-awaited game two of the
finals between Sergey karyakin and
yankova yesterday's game ended in a draw
so today as the all deciding game in
that matchup and of course the world
champion Magnus Carlson still playing
for third place we'll jump right into
the action but first i'm Grandmaster
Daniel narreditsky and yet I get it is a
pleasure to be bringing you the
commentary this morning with former
women's world champion Legend
Grandmaster how you fun uh you fun
thanks again for joining how are you
feeling are you excited about this
decise again this is what it all comes
down to
hi Daniel hi everyone the phone so it's
glad for me to join you again that we
probably will have the commenter for the
World Cup at the last day of this year
we never know maybe we'll see some tie
breaks tomorrow but definitely I'm very
looking forward to the forthcoming games
because as we say it must be very
decisive and I guess uh players
especially at Duda is for fighting
spirit and probably he'll bring us some
interesting games so in general I'm very
uh let's say looking forward to the game
to be started that will be in six
minutes
absolutely and you mentioned the word
fighting the anxious of Judah has had an
absolutely Legendary Run he has not lost
a single game and yesterday he was very
well prepared for kayaking he met him at
every turn it was a pretty quick draw so
the players have gotten a lot of rest
and and I get the sense uh that Duda is
really going to make a push with a white
piece I really don't see young chistuff
making a quick draw and getting this
into the tie breaks of course if the
position ends up being equal that's what
might happen but I'm really excited to
see
um what the opening uh might look like
so
it's going to be absolutely fascinating
and they've come all of this way Korea
can do to have and of course if on
Magnus Carlson played a masterpiece
yesterday so we're certainly not going
to overlook his game today
yeah definitely yesterday uh during our
commentary we already realized his idea
later on when he in fact the Payson F4
and the flying uh completely positioned
on game we were trying to find some
Dynamics we've got actually
you know he just saw something very
solid but strong trying to squeeze the
opponents that's definitely a great
piece of work despite he's not playing
for the final but I guess such a game
would definitely let's say brings him a
lot of let's say enjoyments for the
sermon because we all know that Magnus
actually cares a lot about his game's
quality as well
absolutely
um he was playing with a chip on his
shoulder yesterday and um he has the
white pieces so I I don't see him giving
Vladimir put a say of a quick draw at
this point Magnus doesn't really care
what place he gets he's not getting
first so he might as well play for
raiding and play for the fans and that's
what makes that game so exciting but
Vladimir I mean he's won some games with
black he's a very uncompromising player
so we have two mouth-watering matchups
uh for you today but before we jump into
them we're gonna go on our traditional
couple of minutes of break
and
um when we return from that break
the games from
uh the finals game two will start so
don't go anywhere seat belts as usual
are fastened and mandatory and when we
return World Cup finals are on Deck
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the feed a World Cup and
we are watching The Players await the
gong and the start of the rounds
and uh you find I'm I'm really
interested in the opening between Buddha
and Craig and I have a feeling that A
lot's going to be decided in the first
10 15 moves I just have that feeling you
know
uh yeah totally agree unless do that to
something very let's say very wild very
open but that's not his style I mean he
tried to get some real games in the
middle game so we want to know what's
going to happen but do that is an E4
player or default player
um I think mostly lately he's been
playing D4 but um but you know he's
capable of also playing E4
and he has gone deep or let's switch to
that game
yeah
you're right so we'll see whether he
tried to get some Theory or maybe try to
get some instead of the structure
well we have a you know an IM so like
the start of an Emser or goes and this
could be anything this could be a
Catalan this could be a rogozin this
could be a nimso Indian
and it appears to be a
I'm trying to discern what he played is
it Knight F3
let's see we're about to find out I'm
looking at the camera but it's always
hard to tell
I think it's nice C3 D5 cd5 I'm not sure
and we have the update okay this one
um okay so with this one and we've seen
it before yeah he had the game was uh
was home
I think
some wait are you competitive
some Bishop G5 version p7 you remember
this queen B6 move that we got the same
involve the woman section that's right
and they were they were looking at each
other's game and laughing that's that's
absolutely right yep and that was a
pretty uneventful draw so Vladimir was
not able to create anything and this has
been an incredibly popular line of fun
recently and I think that uh the game I
remember is tari against Carlson and
people lately have been not playing the
move that used to be considered I think
the best which is E4 and I think the
reason why is that after de4 you get the
send game and I think traditionally the
Zen game has been considered better for
white but uh with the Advent of engines
I I feel like black is just you know
players have found out how to equalize
here so there's been a shift to to
playing it more uh in the style of
trying to play against Black's isolated
Queen Pawn rather than trading it so
Bishop G5 E3 castles in Rook D1
yeah that's a good point actually from
my Impressions I also felt I also felt
that the moves like E4 then Nike G5 is
the mainstream but apparently now this
line is the Hope for white to try to get
some real possessions
uh lucky one is it an updated move
compared to the previous game of 30.
yeah that's what I'm on what I'm trying
to remember you know perhaps
somebody could could let us know I I
don't remember what exactly happened
there I feel like maybe a bishop was
developed but in any case
um karyakin has started to think so
something tells me that indeed Rook D1
is maybe not a new move but at least
a move that that wasn't played in the uh
fetise of creation game and it's always
interesting to find I think to face an
opening that you faced with the other
color I never liked facing my own
openings
um and I think traditionally that's it's
hard to face the openings that you play
with one side with the other side
yeah correct about the circuit both
songs has the black faces
so he's having this oh that's right I'm
I'm completely confused I'm sorry that's
right Vladimir put a say it was white
um it's just that I'm not used to Fed a
safe playing something so calm I'm used
to him playing H4 and move three so I
keep thinking there's no way I put a
safe could be playing this position yeah
that's absolutely right correct and of
course was black
um something very important that
sometimes when you see that your
opponent to play the your line I mean
not exactly your line but they know that
you're specialized that and you studied
well and suddenly you sit on the
opposite side and you could be a bit
uncomfortable especially when your
opponent tries a move that you started
hard do you checked a lot but no one has
been played before but you know that I
guess that gives you some very right
during the board
yeah that's why I've always stayed away
from you know playing like the king's
Indian with the white pieces
um now the Nifty opening Explorer tool
is revealing that there are games in in
this position
and I just want to mention briefly that
you know how do we understand this
structure well black has an iqp which
stands for isolated Queen fawn and when
you're evaluating an iqp position there
are two very important things to keep in
mind the first is who has control of the
square in front of the isolated Queen
pod if you know white in this case has
full control over D4 that means this
Pawn on D5 is relatively immobile and
then it becomes more of a weakness but
the second thing is that who's got the
initiative who's got the more active
pieces even if the iqp is weak you could
compensate for it as we saw in better
save karjakan by going you know Knight
C6 Queen B6 playing very very actively
and attacking White's Queen side because
white is not Castle yet
so karyakan believes in this line and
Knight C6 Define I think is the most
natural move
what is he worried about
I guess uh wait but then maybe there's
some Knight E4
Bishop B6
was here I think a move has been played
a weight the development here
we're about to see
uh cracking okay he played the 966.
was planted now a pretty big decision
for JKD as to where
where to position the queen how about
Queen F4 I mean this is clearly a very
doubtful square but not sure if that
could
provide some additional opportunities
Queen F4
yeah enough for I think is interesting
and we're just gonna wait for the board
to update Queen A4 has been played
um
Queen A4 has been played
okay
I mean that makes some sense the queen
is sort of supervising the queen side
um I see six games in this position and
all of them continued Bishop E6 I mean
you have to try to defend the spawn
and after Bishop E6
uh three people played Bishop E2 two
people played Bishop B5 and one person
played A3
so the position becomes a little bit
more peaceful I think here's why it
tries to develop is kingside
yeah so remember the previous game white
set up his Queen these three Bishop on
E2 so that is actually a little bit like
squeezed from White side right so it's
hard to maneuver but now if Queen can be
on A4 and the bishop let's say if
because successfully put on D3 or maybe
B5 short Castle then the c39 to manure
to D4 that will be wealthy
dream positions that white could hope
for
right that night blockade on D4 is
amazing and I keep mentioning how many
games there were in a position uh
remember that all of that is free and
you can do it too if you go to the
chess.com events page uh it gives you
all of the information about a
tournament you can see on the right all
of the games you can click on any of the
game past or present
um or future and review it you see the
results you of course can navigate over
to the openings tab and for any given
position it shows you the number of
games that have occurred in that
position and the breakdown of moves uh
by percentage of wins so we got all
these Nifty features
um at your fingertips and of course all
of this is entirely free chess.com
um if you don't want to hear our voices
I don't know anybody why anybody
wouldn't but uh let's say you have a
hypothetical friend but who still wants
to follow the games this is the place to
do it
all right so I have some interesting
news for you
and Carlson have only played okay now
they're starting to move but something
happened in their game
E4 C6 right
and Magnus thought for
a long time I don't think he I don't
think he prepared for this game because
Vladimir is a Karo gun player I mean at
least karaoke is among his main weapons
uh but maybe that's not what he played
in the last let's say two or three years
because it's like this first like Magnus
played E4
and then fatimer's thought for a couple
of minutes like two or three maybe two
minutes according to the clock now and
decided for the move 66 and suddenly
Magna starts to think again so
you know maybe Magnus can do the board
without any opening preparation
that's one thing
yeah maybe he he said you know he told a
second I'm gonna I'm gonna give you a
break day I want a nice dinner
well then I want to watch a movie I
don't want to prepare for tomorrow
come with a clean slate that's possible
you never know
maybe he's just fed up and tired of
preparing him and sometimes you know
that sometimes that gives you
inspiration
because I remember one of the games that
happened in the woman scoring three back
to many years ago so in the morning I'm
supposed to prepare and but suddenly
there was a kind of music activity of
noise in the hotel and I just happened
to see that after my breakfast so I
decided to join for that one that takes
me like three or four hours I literally
missed my lunch and then I ran for the
games
I turned out to be give me some
inspiration so I actually had a kind of
easy way in the afternoon because my
mother makes up the move older one I you
know tried another line which I thought
okay I didn't prepare anything so I just
go for it and a surprise
so we never know yeah sometimes when you
least expect it uh success strikes
so
by the way here we sold out the magnets
choose the line C4 on the Move four uh I
don't know this uh Carl Kong E5 very
well but to me this C4 is not one of the
major lines I mean let's listen now to
the top two what I knew is like Knight
F3 or H4 I mean there is H4 H5 and then
C4 so how will we move C4 without H4
yeah I've actually played C4 without H4
ah okay and
it's one of the main lines okay
yeah so I guess so what you were saying
you're fine and um sorry just cut off
for one second there but H4 I think like
normally plays H6
uh and just to illustrate the idea of H4
if you go E6 as you normally do in the
caricon this is a big No-No because
after G4 the bishop is trapped
boom boom boom boom and uh you can wave
goodbye to your Biff so H4 is a typical
move in the advanced chiro and after age
64 I've also played like this
but C4 is an old move I think tall
played it I think some of the old guys
in the 60s I used to play the smoke so
E6 Knight C3
and Vladimir responding with Bishop
before I know very little about this
cd5 I played it maybe once or twice but
I don't remember any of the theory
and apparently question for black which
piece to take back so literally two
options
well even three two and a half what I
was thinking xd5 is without
consideration somehow because I felt
like the pawn structure with white
having the E5 Center phone with the
favor is white but maybe I'm wrong
believe it or not all four games to
reach this position uh proceeded with e
takes D5
no but I'm I was under the same
impression so first of all I think Queen
D5 can essentially be ruled out
for example because because after A3
uh you've got a very nasty situation a
black has to take the Knight uh helping
white create this Pawn chain and you
don't want to get rid of your dark Squad
dark squares could become really weak A4
Bishop A3 is an idea whoops no not
Bishop A4 Bishop A3 is an idea here
so and if you play Bishop A5 then you
drive a piece after B4 because now the
queen is saying
but if C takes C5 I guess there's some
reason that that people don't play this
one and it's not Queen A4
um that doesn't win a piece because of
Knight C6
oh maybe some Bishop B5 chat then Knight
E2
and contend for a small Advantage here
in ig7
yeah I always think his Knight to G3 H4
in the future but maybe that's not
something very dangerous
yeah I gotta say uh
I don't dislike Black's position I mean
this is a typical structure that occurs
in many of these positions
could I try to put the pressure
something like Queen A4
seems very artificial but it does create
the threat of course I've been before
and maybe it's not so easy to uh address
yeah I was thinking like just a bishop
c397.
but then you got this A3 to f8 diagonal
so maybe you could even start with
Bishop A3 after Knight pe7
yeah this looks
this looks nice for white maybe not
totally overwhelming black has some
ideas like castles yeah
right and even though it looks really
cool for white to have these Bishops
White's pieces are sort of clustered on
the queen side and black can try to
exploit that by opening up the king side
with F6 kind of French style
yeah or even Knight A5 in the future
with this let's say three Awakening pull
right the C4 Square the C3 Pawn
and black can play A6 at some point and
chase away White's Bishop so
okay so that's definitely one option to
consider
um other than Bishop B5 check or I guess
you could play Queen A4 first if you
want to play that sequence
I don't really see anything else I don't
know why everybody played Ed that's kind
of weird
this seems more natural to me
oh and Vladimir's thinking
yeah I was thinking something like Queen
B3 Bishop B5 after cd5
3.96
before
but maybe you have even Queen A5 here
right
yeah I think that's that's an important
resource
and
it also seems to find for black you just
go 90s every short Castle
yeah Knight G7
short Castle
and everything seems in perfect order I
mean queen takes B5 is also a threat
so that's all of a sudden uh black is
the one with that threat whereas white
was threatening that with the queen on
A4 it's kind of a symmetry in this
position
I like this one black yeah therefore
maybe our direction of trying to attack
this pin for Bishop immediately probably
wouldn't brings anything special so any
other possibilities
yes I mean I could play
D2 D2 yeah the idea is after 96 to try
Knight P5 but you can start with Knight
E7
97 instead of 96. yeah
afternoon quickly Castle
after 97 I was thinking something like
sure and I mean not in this move over
there
something only King side
so Kieran at some point maybe Knight B5
so that's yeah I like this idea it
should be 295
okay I was thinking Bishop E2 here well
that's a bit shaky
oh this should be so you were saying
Bishop B2 at the start or or Bishop b2o
H5 after H5 ah got it so 97 g46 H4 H5
and now Bishop P2 aha
HG
takes and then try to get this Pawn
through
yeah no that's how these Physicians are
played I mean white has to be very
creative here
um another idea that I that I thought
about
uh is but after Bishop D2 one thing that
concerns me a little bit maybe black can
play in ic6 and if Knight B5 maybe
somehow
drop the bishop but now I guess you can
claim that the Knight doesn't have a
good space to develop too
so
white has I guess a game something here
yeah but another thing is why you need
to defend the default pump first and
maybe you also get A6 noisy spring
Knight B4 like double threats
it's black Stern to come to B4 yeah so
it also has this bat I mean backwards
after Bishop E7
right
yeah everything is going everything's
wrong back here D5 my
um he took with the queen
yes he did take with the queen
oh that I think Magnus is going to be
very surprised at that
I mean that is
I I expected that to be the least likely
recapture if I had to rank the three
recap which is of course why he played
it
yeah for me I was on ed5 somehow was the
one that is less possible but of course
I thought cd5 is the most natural right
we were both in agreement about cd5
Okay so
here's what I don't understand
first of all A3 is not necessarily
forced but sorry go ahead we talked
about A3 but if we do not push A3
immediately black May retrieve the queen
and retrieve the bishop okay but uh yeah
maybe he will go like Queen d8 then
Bishop A5 Bishop B6 97 Castle you know
if you do not play A3 or
any other ones trying to capture the
special
yeah I mean you do get positions like
this in this line it's not that black
isn't necessarily that much better when
he has control of D5 but it's also not
something white wants to allow for free
so I don't see a a compelling
case against A3 other than that the
Evolve bar doesn't love it
that is a pretty compelling compelling
case but maybe black can push through C5
well Stephen I'm not sure because you
open up this diagonal a438
so maybe just an idea of three
okay
I will go Knight
I feel like concretely if you go C4
there's always this checkup before
this is the kind of for the save Style
position pushing the envelope here
yeah so it also looks impossible because
here if we go Bishop E2 and then
probably we can just take only four and
start to develop the G8 Knight so he
immediately we should beat you
and no no I'm talking about after Knight
F3 1966
we do here okay so I didn't think yeah
because it said because it said a trap
but I but I think that black has a lot
of good moves there yeah
um yeah there should be two here and now
c4
becomes something to contend with but
yeah maybe Knight she's oh yeah maybe
Knight G7 is in time
oh you want to provoke C4
I still want to go Queenie four actually
yeah that's possible
and I feel like white center as much as
the queen is not happy here
White Center kind of collapses and I'm
not sure that white has anything
concrete for it
so maybe white shouldn't go for A3
because this Pawn structure was a bit
delayed
to be with yeah so
so the question in my eyes I mean ig2 is
a very typical move in such positions
yeah
Knight G2 is where the Knight usually
goes in this line and very often what
you're what you'll see is that
whitesnite heads to G3 and then
eventually maybe to E4 into D6 so both
sides have this have an outpost black is
an outpost on D5 white has a
corresponding outpost on D6
um and I find these structures to be
really interesting now A3
you know is still an existing idea so
windy it is likely
and we might see a position like this if
on Knight G3 Bishop G6
uh or even maybe 97 is more accurate
you're not really afraid of Knight takes
F5
yeah and we now have some Bishop b2h5
here okay 90 E7 uh here
yeah but I mean Bishop Bishop B2 and I
think
I think white is slightly better here
yeah definitely or even get some Bishop
G5
yeah me too
yeah yeah no I think why it's why it's
going to be better in several different
ways
I do want to let's check maybe quickly
back into the do the game just to see
what has happened there but I think
Magnus is about to have a juicy karapan
just an old school
nice car upon slugfest so we're
definitely going to keep our eyes on the
world champion
and
um let's update here well actually no
nothing has happened Queen A4
and
searching it's
Bishop B5 okay play Queen B6 so circus
capture so things have happened oh my
God it's just updated Bishop B6 but
should be 5. B6
hmm
so let's see if any games have been
played in this position yes there is one
game in White Castle in that game
yeah
shop on C6 chop chop and queen C2
and this is quite typical you find I
think you're basically playing for the
C5 square and trying to go Knight A4 and
maybe reposition The Rook to C1
there's a very famous classical game
played by Akiva Rubenstein one of my
favorite classical players against
salvat where he sort of demonstrates
exactly how to play against this hanging
Pawn structure by essentially building a
blockade against the C5 Square so this
structure has existed forever and black
needs to be pretty active here
foreign
on the center
solve the problem of that square
yeah but here it got some problem
because it's 984.
2 takes up six
and
yep swinging the knights A4
but how good is this what if I go you're
going to take on D5 that's already good
enough right 95
Bishop D5 Rook D5 yeah and White's gonna
emerge up a pawn and if you play Queen
takes P2
then uh
maybe black is okay concretely
yeah Knight F6 the queen F6 The Rock
these six
okay this is probably not good
yeah I mean the problem also is that you
know black and Planet Rook on seat I
really don't see black being
too much worse here yeah but the issue
here is you shouldn't push C4 hourly
because then white get 90 for Queen C3
maybe there will be some let's say
control along these dark squares so once
your phone keeps on C5 I guess black
will be fine but tiny things I mean
white probably can create some tiny
initiatives here but right it could
convert it to a wing
but you're absolutely I mean in these
positions you can't talk about a huge
Advantage you you won't win a position
like this in one move it's it's all
about accumulating tiny advantages
so after castles A6
able question whether this A6 is
necessary because I also you know it's a
bit waste of time so for example if we
try something like a rock fd8 whether
white we call this Knight E2 because I'm
trying to see
whether we can just maintain here and
wait to see what white will do
so 92 makes a lot of sense repositioning
as you indicated previously to D4
um yeah but maybe we have
okay I'm trying to do the calculation of
Bishop G4 me too same here I think at
the same time we were both calculating
it like Bishop S6 Bishop S3 Bishop B7
Bishop B2 but Bishop d8 captures but
also Bishop F6 is possible here
ah okay I missed that okay
um not that it's that amazing but it
takes
Bishop F3 okay
yeah maybe that's just clear enough
he's the Bishops just are Desperado
capturing everything so this is good for
black but Queen G4 Queen B5 and funnily
enough the Knight is hanging in the
promising
but white can go I guess Knight F4
and um maybe white has some ideas here
Knight H5 is coming
and you know all of a sudden the queen
and the Knight kind of recombine
and uh you could get in trouble here in
the blink of an eye these positions need
to be treated with a lot of caution
and um I think yes
we're going to show you pretty soon uh
Anish giri the guy the guy has to jump
into every Hot Topic discussion
Magnus is giving time odds in all his
classical games to practice for the
match versus fast enough
wasn't that already obvious I think
anisha's cracked
the the very the essence of why Magnus
is playing the World Cup
Magna spent 5 minutes and 31 seconds on
his second move
our commentators are wondering
I am wondering I think Anish might be
right
uh I guess that's uh somehow thinking a
bit further well probably but I thought
I likely it's just like a
entertaining comic Yvonne didn't you
hear Anish also works as a psychologist
um and uh professor of psychology no no
I'm kidding I'm just kidding but based
on that based on the Tweet
um
well I like his perspectives approaching
things that's always uh sometimes
absolutely yeah creative so that brings
a lot of fun to the Chess World
apparently and also that's making some
sense I mean at least you'll see we're
discussing whether that could be true
it's not something completely melted so
that's super cool
and you know look I I love Anish
um we're on great terms and people like
initial yeah it's great to have top GMS
who have a sense of humor and who bring
light to the game I'm I'm absolutely for
that and I think everybody is the one
time Anish trolled me
was I think this was for this is 2015.
I had a nightmare 2016 rather I had a
nightmare us Championship I got last
three and a half out of 11. and one game
I was playing Alexander O'Neal
um and I was in the midst of a terrible
tournament and ownership played a model
positional game and at some point I had
a bishop on A8 that was buried by a Pawn
on C6 and white had a Pawn on C5 I'm
using the board to show you
uh and my Bishop was buried for the rest
of the game and of course the niche I
think he tweeted something like I wish I
was I'm happy I'm not meredithi's Bishop
today
and let's just say I after the game I'm
talking about about it
I'm not too happy but I was honored to
be troll banished I make no mistake
by the way we have some stuff going on
here Bishop takes F6 has been played
Bishop takes F6
and Knight takes D5 take Stakes Rook
takes five so he's decided on
immediately taking
but we probably will see something
similar
let's say if Bishop takes B2 and in the
future why it captures C6 after short
Castle pieces six zeros return and then
the pawn structure and the material
comparison will be exactly the same as
the line we discussed before
yup yeah like it black doesn't somehow
move the Knight and you know why does
why does a tiny bit better here
there is no doubt in my mind that white
is flying for furniture with with very
little risk
so maybe Rook d8 Let's uh chat few moves
Rook 88
well that's the instinctive reaction is
Rook up D1 or did you wanna work update
I guess that's similar
one
we
Exchange
wow we cannot change is
amazing BC and now not not rotate first
whoops make thread on D1 Pawn is not
touchable but Queen C6 first
and everything is protected due to the
background threats
okay so that's a nice line
which means Rook d8 is not really
possible White Strip continues to
dominate over the D file
and what if black maybe brings the
bishop back to F6
yeah that's a good move
because he also opens up this B file
that makes the b59 a bit Limited
you know sometimes in these positions
you could play something crazy like G4
exactly
wow the evil bird did not hit did not
hit that move I'm shocked
that should be the best move
no because the idea is you create some
looks and you prepare it you're fine
yeah sexual position could be a better
knowing for black to be honest I mean
it's not completely worse but you need
to deal with the pressure
there definitely
F7 they're weakness on B7 literally the
seventh rank
and also your F6 Bishop you need to you
know for example think about whether you
push G6 to leave this G7 square or you
play some other books so maybe by the
way maybe your PA is trying to exchange
as more materials as possible just to
replace the space pressure
and white could try based on your point
about the F7 fund being being we've
repositioned the bishop and again I
mentioned this several times already
obviously colored Bishops in the
presence of Queens favors the attacker
it's not just a draw because the F7 Pawn
is going to be very hard to defend black
doesn't have a light Square bishop and
the pawn is on the light Square so
is doing here and Sergey has struggled a
little bit this tournament to maintain
himself Under Pressure but as he
contemplates his further course of
action and as magnus's karokan unfolds
we are going to take our first break of
the rounds when we return more action
from round game two of the finals of the
fide World Cup don't go anywhere we will
be right back
foreign
[Music]
Worlds Cup and we hope everybody's
calendars are marked because the World
Chess Championship is coming your way in
November 2021 it'll be held in Dubai and
of course nepo and Magnus Carlsen will
be contesting the crown and we are very
excited to announce
that the chess.com commentary team will
consist of a very very special guest
Fabiano caruana will be commentating
alongside Robert Hess that is not going
to be a pair that you will want to miss
and if you wanted to sweeten the deal
even further just.com does have
exclusive video feeds for the world
championship so make sure you tune in in
November make sure you take your take
your holiday make sure it quote
coincides of the world championship
because it's going to be an epic match
and ifana I have a feeling that you know
we've had World Championship matches in
the last couple of years with a lot of
draws and I don't mean that critically
but I have a feeling that this year
things are going to happen I have a
feeling we're going to get more decisive
games than that but what do you think
about that
yeah it could be because the previous
two matches I think of all the players
they were Sergey and Fabiano so both are
well known by their deep chesterlings
very good opening theories but also
somehow relatively solid I say
relatively depends on who they're
comparing because Fabiano clearly also I
think Daniel you mentioned he's good at
some Dynamic positions right and he
likes to figure out all those complexity
so uh having that much draws probably
not really facing style but since he's
facing Magnus I guess both players do
not want to take risks especially I
guess that's kind of strategy for Magnus
because he thought that he has some him
probably even has more Advantage when
the games go into the faster time
control so maybe he's just trying to be
stable in the classical games because in
the match you just need to win so that's
probably part of his strategy but this
time he'll face Neville who clearly has
a very strong relatively skills but in
the meantime of course he developed a
lot for his classical tracks in the last
couple of years just becoming top of the
top so we'll see how the world champion
will manage his strategy and also never
clearly wants some let's say real fights
yeah yeah I I agree and you mentioned
the word risk
I it's of course nobody wants to take
too much risk in the world championship
but I think netball cares less about
that than some of the other players
um I think to nepo he plays the same way
against everybody I think he's just one
of those people who he plays quickly he
has the same style and you know for nepo
of course he's going to feel that he's
going to feel the anxiety of sitting
before Magnus on the world stage with a
gazillion people watching him
um but I just got the sense that he's
going to play the basically the same way
that he normally plays
um and and that's what might produce you
know a very big challenge for Magnus in
addition yeah I think you know everybody
remembers that game uh you find you
probably remember it uh the last
classical game between Fabi and Magnus
where it seemed like Magnus was
you know quite a bit better and then all
of a sudden the game ended
the clocks were stopped and there's a
good video like all of the commentators
reactions because the tab you resigned
did something happen but it turned out
Magnus had offered a draw uh he was so
confident in his superiority in in Rapid
that he offered to draw in a better
position nobody liked it but let's not
forget who the world champion still is
I mean that's actually you know could uh
leads to the both observations one would
say okay so his were Trump usually fine
for this he has good chances why he just
draw without any risks in that position
but on the other hand he knows clear
what is his goal so that's another
special ability for chess player so for
example you came to the board the wisdom
mind that you just need a drawer and
then you thought you got much higher
chances in the coming games and when you
see there's a position you go for it and
sometimes when people thought okay I can
I can earn more I can get more than a
drawer and start somehow you become more
ambitious and that could be a dangerous
signal I guess that also somehow differs
the players at different level because
sometimes they all thought you always
thought something irrational okay I got
translates more I should play but when
things continuing and you suddenly
change your mind I'm not sure you're
able to adjust to the current situation
in a very that's it
um let's say immediately if not that
could be tricky you know particularly in
the world championship yeah yeah so I
mean I can understand about to me is
actually very hard to behave the same
because uh for myself I know that most
likely I'll just follow the games when I
felt since their responses or go for it
but probably that's the one of the
reasons that I'm not at the top level so
who knows well
I mean I think I think you're right I
think I am perhaps slightly understating
the influence of of the tournament and
the environment and I guess we'll see
there's just no way of knowing what's
going to happen the players have been
have been preparing I'm I'm super
excited also to see Nepal's opening
preparation but of course there will be
plenty of time to discuss that the
matches only in November let's check
back into our positions and there isn't
much to talk about here the position
after Rook date C5 is still on the board
and Sergey is
contemplating whether to take on B2 or
to play some other move here
I'm not sure exactly what else is
available maybe Rook d8 first trying to
get rid of that repreemptively
A6
A6 also
Bishop C6 BC sex and trying to capture
back for points of coin
structure that we had discussed let's
say Rook D2 which is yeah I don't think
this structure really you know brings
black something I mean trying to give an
easier task I don't think so
no this is very nasty that pawn is just
a permanent weakness and White's pieces
are perfectly poised to um
to deal with this rough C2 Rook C1 and
honestly this is this is good stuff for
white
so 86
is possible but doesn't seem to solve
all the problems what about Rook da
what should I do here
I guess it takes
yeah takes takes
and
I guess if you Castle then then I'll
take on B2
yeah it's better version because you
control I mean black control the defile
first
right I mean first of all I didn't
necessarily have to take and perhaps
Bishop C6 first is is somehow working
because PC
um
and now let's say Rook dates
rook d8 and some move here you want B3
I'm pretty sure the computer wants to
play B3 and then Bishop C3 track
simplicing E2 and laugh at black space
and say my queen on A4 is perfectly
positioned it's preventing these two
moves which should have been checkmate
yeah actually it's possible
so here white is much better but that
has to be calculated
and Sergey is this position's a little
bit uncomfortable here as he
he's been thinking for a solid almost 20
minutes now I think
yeah but it's critical because that
would decide what type of end game okay
not ending books the kind of the late
middle name will occur and basically
when you enter to a certain type of
structures the red things will be
relatively easier like yesterday Magnus
versus Vladimir right
we'll get into the position with your
vegetable and for the rest of the beer
piece of cake but
here there are few things we check the
bishop versus nine we check the
sacrifice in pools and we tracked some
maintenance with the bishop V2 FDA so
it's hard
it really is and
it is clearly a critical moment I mean
you have every candidate move changes
the nature of the position and wins the
pawn back in a different way and it's
entirely possible cardiacom has realized
that he's worse in every case but that's
the art of Defending it's it's to choose
the Lesser evil to choose the line where
you feel like you have the most
practical chances to to hold a position
now we're not talking here about holding
the game in black is not that much worse
but it's it's very easy to slide into a
very nasty situation they'll counter
player
so I'm curious to see what Sergey is
going to choose
and as he continues uh vacillating over
this decision let's check back into the
game of the world champion
and Magnus did indeed play 92 as we had
sort of begun to suspect right
yeah Queen d8 A3 throwing throwing this
movement and Knight G3 n97
oh so this is all kind of happening A3
Bishop A5 the 93 1970. it's even better
yeah
White's better here in Bishop P2
castles and
after castles why does this very clear
Planet going into Knight C4 potentially
Knight T6
and I think that if you look at this
position with an untrained eye you get
under the impression the black should be
fine because of the control over D5 but
as we indicated earlier
one square does not tell the whole story
White's got a ton of activity
um you know with all of all of his
pieces coming out to Great squares
so
I don't like black Physicians
yeah so this type of story so I could
get this Outpost but this uh and
Salesforce can do nothing unless you
bring one piece there right and I guess
white just need to pay attention for
those counter play ideas like C5 or even
pushing F4 and trying to uh control
these space voltage and maybe one day
trying to develop your king side poles
when you get the full control of the
position because we shouldn't forget
that white has space bondage thanks to
this pong E5
right
yeah that pawn 95 is actually the entire
I mean if you shifted it
okay shifted it to E3 you'd get a slot
but if you took it away
then we would we wouldn't be speaking of
course let's say you put it somewhere
else
you would be speaking about an amazing
position for black super solid but
because this Pawn is here it really
clamps down on Black's position in many
different ways
so
um currently Magnus is thinking here
he's got an hour on his clock
but I said it's got 20 minutes more
and could Magnus be contemplating your
you you brought up this idea of H4 at
some point you find I think that might
be a serious candidate
yeah I was thinking Bishop G5
right and
you don't want to allow now Knight takes
F5 is a serious positional threat
and if black plays Bishop G6
I only go H4
about that H6 okay so maybe bishop G5 is
not a good move immediately
I don't really see a reason not to
develop a bishop P2 I mean of course
Magnus
is known for finding creative positional
Solutions
line I mean not working but interesting
which is Bishop G5 Bishop G6 H4 H6 H5
with the idea hghg and then if you take
on H1 can give a check on F7 wow like an
intermediate move
that's a cool idea well you can play
nice Jesus unfortunately 96 yeah
the Magnus has made a move
he's gone Bishop C4
he did not go Bishop E2 he won Bishop C4
oh okay but white Bishop here
I think he's going live
so first of all he's putting putting
some more eyes on the D5 square but I
think what most people are thinking is
well what is he doing the bishop is
biting on granite there's there's two
pawns here what is the bishop doing
there well I think in the long run
Magnus might be orienting himself toward
a push of the F Pawn
and you'll see this plant sometimes but
the pawn somehow gets to F5 and if
you're able to get rid of the spawn on
E6 the bishop becomes a monster so
I think Magnus might be banking on sort
of the long term virtues of his position
but I don't know I mean it might just be
Divinity Square
yeah or you want to go keep some
possible yeah
when you have three like the activity of
this d185 diagonal
mm-hmm
it should be three point F3
or maybe some nice ce2 Knight F4 but
that's not likely I don't like that no
yeah I mean under under some
circumstances I could see a case being
made for it
and the next question is how black
developed here so maybe like 97 Bishop
C7 Knight B6 Knight bd5
right
but at some point Bishop G5
I guess I guess let's say we Castle
oh just Castle
Castle
yeah black should probably Castle
that goes soon as Knight C4
or even what if I try to force my way in
with Bishop G5
[Music]
and then let me try a four
and you know F5 is almost a reality
because it actually is a threat because
of the pen
and somehow it's it's not easy for black
to prevent it I mean Knight B6 Bishop A2
and then B4 has threatened
so
yeah that might be one one of several
possible ways to handle this position if
feta Sav goes 97.
man I really don't like Black's position
here
yeah because compared to some typical
character lines in this E5 variation
normally it's like D5 C before you play
DC4 Bishop C4 something like that and
now literally you allow CD Queen by
Queen d8 wasting one to two temples yeah
this is this is bad it seems like
White's gotten as you said everything
that he wants because of the tempo loss
and the bishop on A5 is also quite an
awkward piece actually because it it's
neither here nor there it's sort of
staring at the night and if the Knight
eventually moves to E4 it'll just be
staring into open space
but this is often a problem piece for
black and such in these positions I mean
you can park it on B6
but white is can easily reciprocate with
Bishop E3 that's not a big deal
and um
Vladimir I mean of course black against
Magnus
a must-win game if he wants to to keep
the match going
let's be real his chances of beating
Magnus On Demand with black art are
pretty vanishingly low not zero
Vladimir is a beast as she's shown time
and time again but
that's the only thing I think that would
give him hope Magnus is not playing for
a draw
Magnus is out of first place contention
so he wants to win at all costs
yeah so we'll see because the special of
civil is actually the more you look it
seems like a sophisticated move but
we'll see how further self will react
maybe you should play some H6 first it
just to avoid this bishop G5 at
Forefront but that's too slow
plus after we Castle there might
eventually be some sacks or stuff like
that
um
and that's a sign of a bad position on
like every move
uh you play has some sort of a clear
drawback that's that's never good so
we'll see how Vladimir handles this
karyakin has finally made a decision
is
he has played what I would say is the
most sort of natural move
but we couldn't quite find equality
after White Castles I don't think it
exists I think black is just slightly
worse
here what to do instead of Bishop B2
with us yeah we we didn't like either of
the two alternatives
so you kind of have to
bite the bullet here
so White's gonna Castle I would imagine
why it's gonna Castle maybe we'll see
some rock Theater Rocky White Rock T5
Rock T5 and this type of structure
yeah which is which is nasty I'm going
to predict that this position occurs on
the board I'm going to throw out a wild
prediction
I'm going to say this happens G4 is a
very due to move Duda likes these kinds
of moves which multi-purpose moves that
create practical pressure
well you know maybe a woman is not a boy
to play Bishop F6 so maybe some move
like Queen C7
or something like G6
but if you play Quincy
uh-huh sorry yeah no I was just gonna
say that Eve let me see something my
only concern would be you know something
like Queen C2
yeah
Bishop F6 probably a sports now and then
I was thinking maybe here G4
again I just feel like practically
there's so many threats here G5
Lisbon but I agree I think black
certainly isn't obliged
to play Bishop F6 immediately
perhaps even H6
yeah but it will be a tough game for
black
because white has some developing plans
and the black just need to wait there
and be cautious of different threats and
trying to defend you know busy with the
defending ideas so
we'll see whether City will show his
defensive skills here in this game
and Judah has been taking
some time but here he came too
wow he doesn't Castle he goes straight
up to E2 wow
what a decision that is that is a
serious decision right there
now I would caution people against you
know
this is not a crazy move because clearly
black does not have
nearly the Firepower to create problems
against the king
and Duda might be trying to streamline
the process of getting the Rook involved
and keeping the king in the center in
the event of a potential end game that's
that's often the rationale behind
playing this move he might be thinking
that the queen trade might happen
yeah and also sometimes when you want to
push G4 G5 actually can go into probably
even better place compared to G1
right because you're not in the way of
of the king side
huh
so yeah so for example Bishop F6
still G4 is alive and well
how about A6 here
right the king might become kind of a
liability at the same time because if
you take
and go Rook D2 this is a great example
of that if your king was castled light
would be much better but here there's
Queen B5 check
which is an incredibly nasty which is a
very nasty move takes a b and black is
totally fine the pawn structure has been
corrected and the a file has been opened
so
this could backfire on white but not in
the way that light gets checkmated but
more in the way that the King on E2 is
exploited in some way
maybe in this position Bishop C6 should
be avoided yeah maybe just Bishop C4
right
what to do here for
black
I guess dropping the queen back in B5 is
interesting
right
Queen
C7 yeah yeah that's what I was thinking
yeah but maybe you can just go like
Bishop B3
or queen C2 you want I could see there's
maybe four A.M
I was thinking also Bishop D3 which aims
at the diagonal but then G6 can be
played at any
at any moment
yeah but to be honest there's a key too
just seems a bit too much
yeah I agree
I feel like we're trying to dance around
with our pieces to make sure that the
king doesn't get in the way whereas if I
had castles
you know the pieces would have had a lot
more freedom just get the sense that the
king becomes
um kind of a dead weight the wet is
carrying around
and
I think the surprise Sergey I it's hard
to imagine that he anticipated too
well
but I'm not sure if he also considered
kingy too uh well unlikely
yeah I mean
so we were thinking just now we analyzed
Bishop F6
but yet again
A6
yeah so once again it's this dilemma
right if I take on C6
then once again I'm up against the
possibility of Queen B5
and if you play Rook D2 the bishop could
simply drop back
and again Queen B5 is a big threat
so not terribly impressive
perhaps I'll move my Bishop back just
like we did in the other line
well here maybe we can go to V8 and just
try to exchange drugs
right and if I try to kind of shoot for
not moving the bishop
yeah I feel like this might get
unpleasant for black
that's a horrible that's
horrible
so maybe at some point a bishop has to
be moves but you can procrastinate sort
of until the last second just to save
save time and be more flexible
uh you can also play night before here
maybe
I don't know what to make of this move
Rook D7
yeah
Queen C5
okay Bishop F6 has been applied okay so
he decides to drop the bishop back he
will not
not played too adventurously
and
yeah I mean
you won here
here Rook HD one no B1 oh B1
just preparing Bishop D3 and then maybe
you know active activate the queen
yeah there's some tactics in the air
there that work on D5 would swing over
to H5 at some point
so black doesn't have to move the queen
actually there's no direct threat
but at the same time obviously black has
to be very careful I mean Rook 88 Maybe
should be tried
yeah I mean I think Black is Black is
holding on
um
but caution has to be exercised here by
black
so that's that's one way of playing we
wanna D1 also possible
and um it's interesting only three
of the eight World Cup final matches
have ended without tie breaks so
historically most World Cup final
matches do go into the tie breaks
and um remember that most you know all
of those are composed of four games so
it seems like
the further along in the tournament we
go and the less risks
the players are sort of willing to
subconsciously take and that's totally
understandable I think
yeah
but that's an interesting stat
okay so Bishop F6 students thinking
and toggling back to the Magnus game
we had Bishop C4
and it's better to say I'm still
thinking age no we have Bishop C4 Bishop
G6 H4 H6
and what do you make of this development
okay yeah so how about H5 Queen G4 yeah
that looks very natural H5
how exactly does black defend it you
can't have fate I guess taking a page
that's not a move I mean after king of
Faith already
it's ugly it's very ugly
it's almost winning just Castle shorts
and don't play keep playing the game but
what do you I mean what does like do
Rook G8 also looks ugly am I missing
some
maybe some tactical reaction
yeah but Queen G7 is a massive threat
so I don't exactly see
kind of handles I mean what black would
want to do is give up the G7 Pawn
and
then play Maybe King D7 or something
ridiculous like that but it will take a
lot of imagination to figure out a
solution here
and um as fat Asaf does figure out a
solution we're going to go on a quick
break
um and when we come back we're going to
keep on observing these really
interesting World Cup games is seems
like January is putting some heat
on Sergey karyakin and the world
champion is once again in a great spot
out of the opening don't go anywhere
more Worlds Cup finals to come on the
other side of this break
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Worlds Cup in right around 50 minutes we
will be joined by none other than Vichy
on a five-time world champion he will be
joining us yet again today what an honor
it is to have is she uh in the studio he
provides so much Insight so he'll be
joining us right on the hour in 49
minutes
and uh hopefully by that point uh the
games will still be as entertaining as
they are now and given the complexity of
the positions
uh I think they will be so
in The karyakan Duda game
we have
um I think a doubling of the Rooks on D1
which yeah he was employed
and we were kind of debating in between
Rook B1 and Rook D1
and do that deciding on
Rook D1
yeah and I guess the obvious uh reaction
here would be Rook da to try to exchange
both of the rocks
so let's wait for it to update there we
go
and uh Rook FDA to Rook 88 so let's
Erica
work FDA
yeah maybe
I don't know
the email bar seems to prefer Wi-Fi
a heavy margin
Rook D7 is interesting
if take there of T8
yeah that's what I'm trying to puzzle
out I can't seem to
I can't seem to figure out a course of
action takes takes Rook d8
and it looks like black
neutralizes White's position here
there's questions
exchange twice only d8 and then Bishop
d8 Bishop C6 about Queen B2 check first
C6 bc6 and then maybe 94 this point or
not yeah let's pull probably just a
little lost
due to the background
and if Queen B2 now you have a very
pretty score on F3
yeah King F3 that's a really nice line
and now the spawn is lost
and um
if you play Queen C6
then this end game probably is really
bad
maybe you could take on A7 I don't rule
that out but I feel like this engine is
just terrible for black yeah
no this is much stronger than the G1
Square
no this is this is this is a atrocious
for black
and I just want to drive everybody's
attention to the fact that this is what
you know games at this level are all
that it's you know you seven move
sequence and at the end yes you win just
the pawn but it's not just upon to these
players you know upon in an end game
like this is uh is essentially game over
so
um it like that's how you have to win
positional games you have to be as
nimsovich said you have to be
happy to celebrate small victories good
players celebrate small victories
and it seems like
is firmly in charge and you might be
celebrating a small victory of putting
karyakin under pressure in the open hand
Sergey has struggled with black in in
this tournament
pretty unequivocally
yeah I mean that's a best surprise to
see because he's supposed to have a very
solid opening repertoire
yeah and he does
yeah sorry no go ahead yeah we see that
most of the white players actually uh
just trying to play with him some
positional positions with tiny age and
then trying to enlarge it both here well
here we still need to see how game will
continue but also previously when uh Sam
Chapman played him with white pieces
both the classical game that and them
and catalog but for example he's playing
with feather say before trying to create
something but he defended well so maybe
somehow he's not very happy to defend
those Sunny slightly worse positions
like here
yeah you might be the Minister of
Defense but maybe his term is ending
and um the reality is that nobody yeah
nobody wants to defend this amount of
positions in one tournament
and you you mentioned the pr the concept
of people getting into these slightly
better positions and squeezing him
and and with Sam you know there was that
panicky move at five at some point
he's been you know getting these
situations where we're used to him
holding the position with computer-like
precision and
he is human and you know some sometimes
you have tournaments where one
particular area of your game suffers
more than others but obviously we're
jumping the gun here I don't think uh we
can talk about any kind of big Advantage
yet I just think the best
characterization of whites of Black's
position here would be annoying you know
this is slightly annoying to play for
black
but I'm I'm convinced that if if Sergey
is careful here he should be able to
hold this
yeah with accurate defense
Maybe
[Music]
look
maybe G4
yep our favorite move
involving what is the A8 Rock to the
square up I think it's better
yeah roxy8 yeah so it's been played he
wants to reinforce his Knight
and that will conceived later on if the
nine moves of course it could
potentially have access to the second
rank
okay
so now the question is what is JKD do in
response I like the idea of G4
but I feel like
he will be searching for maximum here
what else exists because the G4 might
face A6
right
now we're running into some concrete
problems because if the bishop drops
back to C4 already there is
some funny business with night before
but you get real pieces maybe Europe
okay
but I would argue that already these
kinds of tactics are probably Black's
favor because White's lost a little bit
of the one-sidedness that with which
he's been playing maybe bishop D3 should
be played
with the idea of night before Rook D6
wow oh
but
um apparently black has some very strong
with tort here
um
a simple move
yeah and the work's kind of stranded
here
yeah if you move your Bishop away he's
gonna have charcoal C4
right
and then Queen takes a two is the threat
Queen takes G4 yeah I feel like here
White's position sort of comes a part of
the seams a little bit
and I really like your idea of A6 in
response to Q4 so
my guess would be
white should do something a little bit
more
I'm not gonna say careful but I don't
know how to you know something a little
bit more
solid I guess
but what and and this is where I think
kinky too
is um is something that perhaps doodle
would regret after the game if if it
ends in a draw let's say
because it's it keeps getting in White's
way here
whether it's a check on C2 that becomes
possible or I check on this Diagon that
King on E2 is
it's not in any mortal danger but as I
said previously it's it's always
susceptible to these anoint little
checks
and moves with temper
yeah a bit too creative
well to be honest and we're seeking into
time to time but um
a bit unlikely when the flag already get
this openc file and open the file
right
okay yeah okay see it was nice
yeah and preparing Asics actually
suddenly it solved the problem of the
isolated forms and it gets some threads
to break this setup with Bishop C4
Bishop B3 coin somewhere else so now the
question for white
yeah to me there's actually two I I see
this game going one of two ways
um I think the likelier scenario is just
a quick draw of some sort I think Rook
AC was an incredibly precise offensive
the other scenario is that Duda I can
find some way to
prolong the pressure and the game goes
on for you know 40 50 moves is Duda
keeps trying to poke and prod
but the more I look at this the less
kind of
appealing options I see in terms of
trying to get scenario two to work maybe
bishop D3 immediately what do you think
of this move
I'm trying to prevent you know night
before because of Rook B5
and of course repositioning this bishop
on this diagonal
um and if we go some more like Queen
before
okay
that's a really good move
another thing to move
simply find the position
geez that's that is annoying because if
I take white is liable to being worse
here because if you allow Knight A2
you're busted the night's coming to C3
what does it might even do here I mean
you got to go five
which move I mean I mean just for saving
trading on your own terms here yeah
makes takes B6 something like this
and this is equal
and and I'm sure not black doesn't even
have to take A6 Maybe
this is a funny
a funny and a funny exchange of moves
because neither side wants to trade
Queens
and both sides
not trying to get the other to trade on
their terms
so yeah that's a big problem before is a
big problem
yeah
but what else
I don't know and the other thing you
know is if white goes Rich to two if
white says all right you know what let's
take the second rank under control whoop
Bishop comes out to C3
again it's annoying okay you and can
play Bishop's sister because I was
thinking like a69 before that too
oh King E2 was it was it was a serious
inaccuracy that's I'm almost convinced
of that
yeah it at least gives black some hope
like knowing the direction where to put
the pieces and which effort to
concentrate on
right I I think Judah will play G4
eventually because I I just feel like
you know as the expression goes once
you've said a you have to say B
well I doubt because maybe he realized
that this idea will play something solid
okay
yeah I I agree I mean I think
I feel like in these situations
sometimes you feel like you're in too
deep and you have to justify
a more liking it too
obviously due to understand he's not
going to just make a move on General
grounds
so
so maybe we'll have a look for the other
game because we
have eight happens over the board yeah
so Queen G4 Peter say I've decided to
uh yeah
this is really bad
it's really bad
oh gosh oh because I but the kind of
fiber can take
uh sorry oh sorry I I don't know what to
do go ahead no no actually uh today my
internet got some problems so I will
always like few seconds delayed so I
didn't see the current position unless
you told me with cancer first and the
screen the picture shows later
oh no worries yeah so this is the
position the current position I was uh
Knight of five has not been played but I
think that's Carlson's idea because
after it takes
you're like what are we doing we're
wandering the night nope Queen drops
back to F3 x-raying the pawn and F5 and
white is winning I'm just coming to D6
look at this bishop that's a bishop and
use Gary would tweet about
and then Bishop F5 then three
again you know nine 1966 or it's a G3
and Black's position is incomplete in
outer collapse
yeah am I overestimating magnus's
position or
do you agree that it's really bad for
black fully agree because normally even
you know you switch the position of the
broken King like Dr f8 came to h8 it's
still in favor of white but this case
just much worse
yeah and I mean
yeah Carlson plays some accurate to move
older like Knight G3 H4 just directly
you know trying to put pressure before
black Castle short though I doubt
whether black needs to go for the bishop
G6 then Bishop H7
yeah and I mean
yeah yeah I mean this opening choice of
C4 my Magnus always seems to choose like
the right I mean a lot of the time he
just seems to choose exactly the right
opening to play the opening that's going
to cause us upon in the most
difficulties
and you know feta Sev I think Bishi
mentioned this yesterday it's just so
frustrating you've had an amazing
tournament and guess what you're playing
Sergey kuryakin you lose then you're
playing Magnus Carlson as a reward and
if you lose the last three games of the
tournament you know you have this bad
taste in your mouth
um but let's not lose sight of the fact
that Vladimir has still had an amazing
event regardless of how he does today
it's not easy to play Magnus that's I
guess that's the lesson from today
yeah
overall he has a fantastic tournament
but always the people somehow are you
know remembering more about what
happened the latest so his latest three
games might be not as comfortable as his
previous games and matches so we'll see
whether he could successfully defend
this one because if he can defend this
one that's a great success to be honest
under this position
yeah that would be an incredible defense
but you can just see in the body
language
uh that Magnus Magnus knows he has this
under full control what if you played
Knight B6 here no that's not going to
cut it I guess
even
Bishop's face he's sick yeah
and then before any moment you want
yeah I mean this is when you could even
drop the bishop back
I'm going to say this is almost lost or
black
um particularly because this place this
kind of position plays right into
magnus's strengths you know converting
these kinds of positions with a big
initiative which aren't too Tactical
but yeah I mean this is just
this is garbage
for black
yeah bad opening decision seems like
maybe starting from this bishop before
there was this move Queen D5
yeah this was a mistake I think we did
it yeah
I think 25 was a mistake and I think
either Edie or CD we still the mystery
of e takes D5 and why it has been
exclusively played
uh we didn't solve that mystery but I'm
quite sure that either of these moves is
revealed even by the evil bars is
is fine the difference is not that huge
with Queen D5 but it just gets the
structure that's incredibly hard to play
the C4 Square the king side play The
Pawn on E5 White's got too many pluses
in this position and black has lost too
many Tempe
okay
so
wow and and if you believe only uh 15
moves in this is already there's no
Rises
only 15 Moves In
wow yeah I remember I am
who was I playing
I I rarely and I resigned very late but
I think I had one game
I don't remember who it was against but
it was some 2700
and I was an I am at the time and I had
one of these positions and I just
resigned I mean I was just sitting there
just so disgusted
in my position that I I knew that it was
the wrong thing to do to resign
but sometimes you just the more you look
at your position the more disgusted with
it you become
and I feel like that's that's I'm not
advocating for Vladimir to resign by any
stretch nor will he but that's that's
how bad this is
yeah well he realized for sure that his
position is
kind of very fragile
but as a player we still need to find
the most and the most tough moves to
create difficulties for your opponent to
convert the advantage
absolutely you gotta
you know you gotta ask yourself what
would Magnus do with black what would
Magnus do if he was playing himself
trying to make it as as hard as possible
well we'll see Vladimir well the time is
not an issue if he's got over an hour as
per usual
and I imagine he's going to
he's going to take a while here trying
to come up with some
some defensive idea
okay
um
let's switch back for a second to the do
the game because we did have a move and
it's Bishop C4
and we did consider this I think
did we
I think we did I remember mentioning
like Knight before it would be five or
maybe that was in reference to Bishop D3
though yeah that was having the bishop
Israel I don't think we checked Bishop
C4 under the specific position uh-huh
and it actually might be a very nice
move or
Queen before
yeah
yeah still this move
and
again if you take then white actually
loses because the bishop on C4 is lost
and um
wait what does Judah do here is it Queen
B3 Maybe
again trading on your own terms
yeah
that's a nice idea
that's a nice idea and if Queen takes B3
you can solidify everything
by taking nope I guess not with the pawn
but taking the mission for some reason
and then what comes into D7
and um
well one was the take back was a bishop
we wanted to create to to block the C
file
I said it again
no I was wondering why do not just take
back it was a bishop because uh maybe I
get get you wrong because I thought you
put ab3
yeah but the email bar didn't like it so
I'm going to put it back I guess a6b5
maybe and the bishop cannot be sustained
on C4
yeah I mean this ab3 is a bit weird to
be honest because your Bishop can
not just successfully stay on the C4
Square trying to plug this
yeah that's what I missed I kind of
superficially assumed that
the pawn anchors the bishop but the pawn
actually restricts the bishop and we do
give you know referential treatment to
our wonderful hard-working team of
producers and
particularly heralded by dick who has a
question actually for us
um if I may and Vic is asking why didn't
we consider playing A3
before Bishop D3 and um there's the idea
of this is to prevent night before very
prophylactic I think he needs to change
his last name to uh car pop foot
thinking yeah
I think the reason might have to do with
the fact that it's it's not quick enough
and this gives black a tempo
and I I often Advocate this to people
and and to students in almost every
position I think in a lot of positions
you have to have kind of an internal
metronome
by which I mean you should be kind of
loosely aware of how many moves you have
to accomplish an idea this might be one
this might be two because White's King
is so wide open and white species are so
loose
I feel like this move
is a little bit too slow and I feel like
this gives black
enough time to to consolidate but I
don't really know how so I do like a3a3
Bishop D3 certainly was an idea worth
considering maybe Rook FDA maybe
something like that anyways way before
it's been played
yeah I guess one of the other point is
even after A3 A6 that when your prom
moved from A2 to A3 okay you control B4
but you lose the control of B3 so
basically no longer it would be a
defended or protected Square for the
bishop or the queen that means that you
lose the set of possibility for the
queen side in the longer sense I I don't
know if that would really Breeze wide
anything or maybe you know
right holes
agreed agreed you you're one hole is
patched up and another is created okay
so Queen B4
and here we are expecting fully
expecting Queen B3
which will be played quickly it's the
only move
yes okay there's a question
exchange coins and try to
try the drugs but that of the face is
Rook D7
so boom you're saying take six and rock
FDA runs into
redox cd8
because the F7 is productive in that
case
ah so you want to play
our cd8 so that the raw kind of Fate
remains to protect that Bond
yes but still white go for rock D7
yeah yeah this is very very unpleasant
and um
the issue after Rook D7
is that is that it's unclear how black
unwinds so let's go Queen B3 takes takes
and the line we're looking at is rook
cd8 and Rook D7 very common idea moving
along the file that you are controlling
and queen B3 has been played
this is super super nasty
and white is totally dominant here and
this just shows you how opposite colored
Bishops can actually be an unbalancing
force in a position it's not always all
about
opposite College Bishops causing garage
tendencies
they can actually be the reason that the
position is winning
and um we will see how Sergey handles
this but it is getting quite unpleasant
for him
in this world cup deciding game we are
going to go on another short break
and when we return we will continue
monitoring duda's efforts to squeeze out
this Advantage he's playing phenomenal
chess Magnus Carlson seemingly crushing
Vladimir fettise both of those games are
unraveling quickly when we come back we
will bring you updates from those games
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Worlds Cup remember there is new merch
available and you do not want to pass it
up because using promo code World Cup
all one word you can get 10 off all
chess.com Merch this offer ends August
7th two days from now so those of you
procrastinators who still want Chestnut
come swag and you want to discount it
make sure to go to go.chess.com merge
enter promo code World Cup for 10 off
all just.com swag
all right so we're watching game two of
World Cup finals between
Sergey kayakin they are playing for
first place and Magnus and Vladimir
Felice playing for third place if you're
just joining
um it used to be the case that the
finals were four games this year the
finals are two games long of course
there will be a tiebreaker tomorrow if
necessary for either of the matchups
the way it's going right now
uh it's totally up in the air whether
diet breaks will be necessary because
dude is doing a phenomenal job
putting the heat on Sergey karyakin who
has just
uh yupon taken the queen on B3 and here
it's very important to take with the
bishop
yeah and I was just thinking you know
after Bishop B3 how about this move
Knight B8 trying to stop Rook D7 and
then to exchange dollar D file
um
yeah because I didn't see the way to
stop Rock D7 I literally felt like when
white Xerox successfully controls the
seventh rank it will be a disaster
absolutely no I really like that move
and you know what I'm thinking of I've
been thinking about G4 even here again
yeah
but not the only moment I think maybe
also I I do like Knight be it I think it
it might be the only the only move that
preserves
a semblance of decency I was also
thinking in 92 Maybe
the idea being I have to Rook FDA I want
to go 94.
okay then Bishop E7 no I'll snap this
off no they've got 96.
dude yeah maybe not the end of the world
here but definitely not what Mr kayakan
is looking for it has been played okay
so now we'll see which plan do that it
hasn't played wow
yeah
awesome
and that is a really really nice way
I would I would argue you found that
Knight D2 is the sort of natural move
and after Rook FEA the black tries to
prevent white from going to E4 watches
you know no problem I'm gonna come to C4
such a night
yeah this is a knife that night a knife
Jumping All Around the board
no I think he's playing it too and I
think he's going to do it quickly too I
think he's going to do it within two
minutes
I think he feels it
although no not not necessary he's got
54 minutes
I'm gonna put put out the fact that this
is extremely extremely concerning
he's in he's in serious trouble now on
the same game
yeah
because no chances
exactly no counter play and she knows
the confidence with which Judah is
playing you just get this sense of the
Mojo a wheel's turning in his brain
and every decision
presses the gas pedal down further it's
like he doesn't take a breath he just
keeps pounding at it and
keeps creating problems from the very
first from the very first moves it's
insane and I'm going to say if on this
decision to take on F6 and take on D5 I
know that it looks easy but it's not it
is not easy to understand that this
position obstacle or Bishops or King is
uncaseled as of yet that this position
is actually better for white and this
level of positional decision making King
E2 I think was inaccurate but he
followed it up beautifully with Bishop
C4 and perhaps Queen B4 was a mistake I
don't know
92 I think oh no no it has not been
played yet
yeah coin before might be a bit and I
can write about very tempting because
you feel like you know when you uh enter
into the end game there might be more
chances but you know it requires me that
how Sergeant lost one of the previous
games with uh chakra in this m game
yeah he has gone G4
man I like Knight D2 though
maybe black will just play some
moves like B6 and then 94 Bishop E7
preparing for Rook V8 well no
Excel is still losing but somehow trying
to maintain there but you know even one
day you might sacrifice with 057 then
capture A7 capture F7 right
I mean I think GeForce G4 is clearly
also very good
I think both moves are excellent
no this is uh the problem is still you
cannot play Rook d8 because he gets 95.
I may exchange everything
or or even here I think yeah
oh yeah because even stronger I was just
calling the greedy and Capture One Call
be happy with that
yeah but how do you accomplish because
if you take on da your G5 funds are
hanging in the end
you can play without it
you wanted to play it straight away just
take everything oh my God yeah yeah
gotcha gotcha yeah
but maybe we'll work but maybe there's
Bishop C7
yeah but I mean he can play G5 first
White isn't really spoil for Joyce here
so I guess G6
makes the most sense to me at least
together
Bishop G7 but perhaps now it's time to
open the gates and go naked too H4 H5
and that's
oh gosh that is nasty nasty nasty
paralyzed
no way for the night no way for the Rock
yep nine moves Ricky So this reminds me
of the Shanklin position
in the sense of no counter play and and
the night Maneuvers too like shingling
had it never night when we were just
like this
well you get one plan Knight A6 Knight
C5
which is why I think maybe Knight D2
makes sense
but H4 also makes sense because after
Knight A6
I think you make it in time you just go
H5 and something like H6
okay maybe yeah
three Bishop Bishop C3 yeah
yeah so I think maybe 92 is more precise
here but who knows well now we gather up
the eight
right
I'm gonna go here
take on D5
okay
now what am I going to take with oh this
is like choosing between
a Peroni pizza and me spaghetti
meatballs I want both Bishop takes D5
so greedy roxies
it's
196. oh no no no no wait a minute
no
thinking about the exact crazy tactics
um
I mean you know worse comes to worse you
can always just
arrows drop your Bishop back but if Rook
takes D5 maybe this is more this is uh
more accurate
yeah
and then Knight C6 98
very hard
[Music]
disgusting
yeah the point is why you do not have
some P5 A5 A4 trying to make use of your
extra ball on the queen side
nothing and why does this F4 or five
idea on top of everything why does so
many plans it's so easy to improve the
position
yeah that's typical even when you
exchange the night that's the drug
Bishop end game would be hard we as
we're seeing some famous games but now
it's a night here I guess that only
favors White
no it clearly I think Sergey going into
this end game deeply underestimated to
the extent to which
he has no activity and is essentially
paralyzed and perhaps also the extent to
which y can improve continually position
so maybe that's all you're right
yeah it's easy to say in 2020 hindsight
but looks like Rook FDA
maybe but the the engine actually
already indicates quite an advantage for
for white and after Rook D1
it appears that A6
might have been the most precise path
too holding A6 Bishop C4 okay d8
and white is slightly better still after
something like G4
so King E2 perhaps
perhaps this move never really gave up
the advantage
wow
tuna is playing like a machine
in this tournament
yeah would you say this is lost or
do you I would I would wondering what
kriyakin's objective chances here are
no it's not losing but
it's not far from it
um not that far I mean probably black
hood collapsed very soon to be honest
right
and as Sergey contemplates the move
speaking of black collapsing
let's check out the FedEx position
where Carlson okay so Knight F5 happened
and this exact thing happened 96.5 as we
discussed uh-huh yeah
and and I think this is
um absolute crisis mode now what is the
threat I believe the threat is Knight G3
so let's make a random move just to
illustrate why is Knight G3 so scary
because we are threatening to take on F5
and if the bishop moves we obviously
have
Bishop takes E6
with a crushing attack
so how should black address this queen
H4 comes to mind
but there is something here yeah
your midnight G3 Bishop G4 but then that
was the idea
well queen of four maybe it's kind of
stocking just a little bit tied down
here just a tad Bishop takes E6 is a
threat
and F3 like different rules
I resign
um
Mr scheibel would be proud of me I
resigned there
um and could a case be made for taking
honey for no because you're gonna go
have four out of five and the game is
going to be over
yeah like maybe Knight B6
maybe this is the way to defend
you may after extending only four yeah
yeah yeah yeah and I have a 4.95
F5
so this is too slow
this is super slow as I said even and
the drop exchange uh the queen king
exchange positions still in favor why
because you've got this face shot oh you
only Exchange
well I mean and probably not not
necessary just Maybe
41 preparing e-sticks
I have a funny story about that I am I I
am participated in
many years for many years the U.S chess
school was which is a camp for you know
for talented young players that I don't
know how I made it there
um I impersonated somebody nobody
talented uh but it was taught for many
years by uh do you know Gregory kaidanov
uh yeah
so Grisha um you know and I love Gregory
he's sort of a classic Russian and
no-nonsense uh coach loves doretsky and
the camps were a blast but there was one
year where
um we had this circulating meme
throughout Camp which I started
um where I would propose a line that I
knew was bad Grisha would refute it and
then I would say and I lose
um so I would propose some sacrifice he
would refute it and I lose
and I he was getting frustrated
um progressively throughout the camp and
on the last day I did that again
and in Russian in front of the whole
room
he basically he just lost his skill and
he said Daniel
um can you just be serious just this
once
um and I I don't remember if he
if I think he he threatened to kick me
out which I entirely deserved
but if anybody has any illusions that I
was
not a troublemaker or a sorely mistaken
let's just say I was as red as a
tomato and 90 degrees Sun
anyways move has been played
tonight
[Music]
Bishop D2 yeah and then maybe A5
yeah and then maybe just to play some
simple moves like a drug KC War oh well
maybe that's a bit wasting of time
now Bishop D2 would be a logical one and
after A5 the question is
what's next
right Bishop D2 I think one could argues
independently a good move because it
connects the Rooks the question is how
to improve subsequently the position
and
white could play uh something like
B4 I thought maybe
what do you make of this
my idea is after A4 I want to go B5 and
get the bishop db4 obviously black is
not going to go A4 but
just to illustrate and
if you allow me to take on A5 I want to
trade the dark squared Bishop so that I
can slam a knight into D6
all right uh I will take
gift me the poem
yeah it's also oily
so I guess taste yeah 96.
and before seems yeah
nice one nice and clear
yeah I think because this screen opens
the second front and that's a very
common technique when your opponent is
hanging by a thread sometimes you just
want to strike on the other side of the
board where
you know your opponent doesn't have
sufficient resources to hold things
together
and um I think there's many approaches
here that Magnus could take I love his
time management he's got 34 minutes for
anybody other than Magnus I'd be
concerned but for Magnus this almost
feels like like in
eternity
so
this this is dire dire situation for
Vladimir but um I'm very curious to see
how Magnus is able to invert this
Advantage because he is of course the
ultimate master
in the realm of
converting advantages and driving them
home
but I think Bishop D2 will be played I
think it's very very natural reasonable
move part to resist
yeah just after A5 which direction
Magnus will go for
all right back to G3
doesn't go Bishop he wants to chase the
bishop away first
Bishop H7
well we'll see
I mean he could still play Bishop B2
afterwards
okay so Simpson doesn't want to allow
this bishop E4 opportunity anymore
I have a suspicion that he wants queen
g445
wow okay
but
that has its own issues because in
response to F4 black could play F5 in
some of these positions
nice idea
so what you know what Magnus produced
Bishop D2 and then move the queen
sorry go ahead yeah just say after F5
maybe white can just Retreat the queen
back and then your Bishop was fully
blocked on H7 with the weakness
the position only still be much better
it's buried so let's say we're dnf4 F5
just saying well thank you very much uh
say goodbye to your Bishop
and then the pawn 96 is also weak so
the aid Bishop F7 King G8 the th7
finally
Bishop G and Bishop F7 H7
okay
I think
clued me into the fact that he was he's
trying to get the bishop off of F5 stick
you could try to land a pawn there
I don't know if this is the most
convincing
um
I'll be honest with you if I'm I'm not
sold
on the fact that f45 Queen E2 is
totally clear
like let's say just let I want your plan
Bishop G8
I feel like D5 in one of these positions
are gonna happen
yeah it can happen one day
maybe just pick something C1
preparing D5 but they've got Bishop B6
okay I mean even here before I guess
can be contemplated
yeah this is very hard for black
yeah every one of these Physicians
and
if you could land a knight on H4
that'd be nice
I feel like Knight H1 and one of these
positions might be interesting but not
not yet of course
um and this is
this is a disaster for black and in
every
basically in every every situation so
I think Vladimir will play Rook d8
because there isn't much that black can
do if black dry C5
code black try C5 or is he bringing on
his own demise
maybe bishop D2
a bit more prophylaxis against CD
then Rook C1
he has your king is still in the middle
and you're both Strokes are disconnected
and you try to open up the lines
why is everything so nastier for black
every every line is looking terrible
yeah today both sex games are suffering
they really are and um well we will not
be suffering after the next break
because we will be joined by none other
than vishyan Anand so we'll go on
another very very quick break just to
get vishy into the broadcast and when we
return the three of us I'm going to keep
analyzing these really fascinating games
there is a possibility that a winner of
the World Cup will be decided today
we're two hours into the round don't go
anywhere seat belts have to remain
fastened and we'll be right back with
vishy
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to the
2021 fide Worlds Cup you're watching
Finals game two potentially the decisive
rounds and it is a great honor to be
joined once again by five-time world
champion Grandmaster vision and vishi
thank you so much once again for joining
the commentary booth and um
what are your Reflections so far it
looks like Sergey is potentially in
Mortal Danger
yes um I mean this is huge
the very fact that he has put his Knight
on B8 means that it's not coming
anywhere though I think um
if he could get Knight A6 then it meets
it threatens Knight C5 as well as myth
Rook D7 at my C5 but the problem is G5
is going to crash that party
so for the moment I think he has no way
to free himself
G5 is a huge threat we were thinking
maybe G6 actually wait Knight A6 G5 let
me go Bishop B2
and now if I put a knight on C5 that
improves matters a lot for me
maybe this is what
is what can you see something after
Knight S6 instead of G5
instead of G5
let's say is there anything again Knight
T5 is a pretty serious
yeah one could say thread
can I reposition
but G5 if you go Bishop B2 then I don't
know it's my follow-up
maybe Rook B5 then
B5
after G5 Bishop B2 ah G5 yeah yeah
that's okay and Bishop F7 is a threat
yes agree no but then I can play Knight
C5 I have Knight C5 actually and in the
end you have Knight A4 wow
no but then you get uh yeah your Cafe 90
for all company
hmm
so this position
yeah I feel like this bishop can be
exploited someone but what if you start
with H6 played by the way no but this is
terrible because I'll go H4 and if you
then play Knight A6 I go G5 takes takes
Bishop wherever C3 B2 and G6 that's the
big difference that's just oil onto the
fire
yeah because now you can't do the same
line because I'll throw in G6 in fact I
was thinking of G6
Knight G5 anyway right afterwards but
uh but now it's a piece of cake I can do
this yeah
no it's a cherry on top oh this is
so obviously he's not going to follow up
with uh he'll probably play G6
G5 Tech Stakes but still I don't like
hit six because I will now have once I
get a Pawn on G5 I should be doing very
well uh Knight H2 G4 I have Knight H4
threatening a capture just all sorts of
nice
maybe he wants some H4 Rock d8 in case
to keep the penis
Point H4 but okay let's try G5
yeah thanks takes Bishop E7 G6 it's over
that's again the problem politics
yeah there's Bishop I mean I was going
to say 95 and I realized wait I still
have even G6 I don't even need Knight D5
you're gonna instantly played H4
yeah
and what could Sergey want here
because it seems worse than every
version to take hghg
yes and G6 you were saying G5 takes
takes Bishop G7
there's many nine Maneuvers something
strong but even even uh H5 G5 Knight D2
looks very strong to me just put it a H5
G5 Knight D2 can I go King I assume G5 I
think E7 seems strange because I can
take Tech and G5 even maybe
yeah but it's possible that King G7 is a
resource okay we'll get to this but at
least for G5 I'll go Knight D2
so H5 G5 Knight D2
yeah and if you go Rook f8 to stop mate
the I have Knight C4 even but I have
Knight F1 G3 as well so which is a nice
one yes
I think after H4
but H5 King G7 might be more annoying
than I thought
okay we're gonna find out he played G6
so let's see
somehow I feel like G5 is more I mean if
G5 works then
that position is so juicy
so G6 G5 takes takes Bishop G7 and now
you mentioned Michelle I think Knight H2
is a possibility was one idea and then
to play a forking F3 and just sit like
that
alternately maybe it's time for Knight
D2 actually
because everything is crashing magnitude
is great
yeah
so maybe if you wanted to go Bishop C3
Bishop C3
C3
and then Knight H2 must be quite decent
because I'll have a night at six maybe
somewhere
yeah black is sort of continually
paralyzed here
I think our uh our attitude when we have
to suggest a white move already suggests
that our evaluation we agree on the
evaluation
yeah probably Bishop C3 is to make a
white move
yeah at least Bishop C3 allows King G7
in some positions so it's definitely I
think better than Fisher G7
um Bishop C3 and then how should I get
around
so G5 HG HG this is the critical
position if y plays G5 maybe maybe we
should see three I have Rook C1
because I think exchanging one pair of
Rooks doesn't hurt me in fact it weakens
F7
mm-hmm
and if we play because if you play
Knight A6 I go to Rook B7 Knight C5 and
then just Bishop takes F7 so that's at
least
something that I have
oh that's very nice and then Rook C3 in
the end
and if we go
right that too maybe King G7 just sort
of a semi-winning move but now the
bishop doesn't yes a way back that's
that's true
uh I I could go
yeah I don't I don't have a knockout
because it shows how important I'd be it
was because it takes the most important
square away from it
G5 had G5 Knight takes G5
it's just instead of
um
right just going for the direct attack
so or if I want some Razzle Dazzle I can
go G5 head G5 Hitchcock H5
oh
that actually looks really really nice
and black could get checkmated
momentarily asking G7 I take on G5
and then if we take twice I can double
on the G file and it feels like I'm
gonna win a pawn at least
drops back to E4 potentially
wow and if you take take
it looks nice
yeah so you're saying after King G7
Knight G5 takes takes yeah I mean G5 is
the more natural move head G5 but then
Bishop C3 and uh how to I don't know how
to give a knockout blow there
yeah H5 looks
really really nice nfg4 then of course
The Rook defense is fun so you can
probably go
it's a knight H2 G3 and Knight Knight G4
and already uh hg6 is winning because
you cannot allow a discovery
right it's not about taking the puns
it's about taking the right pawns here
at the right time
[Music]
so
incredibly nasty here black
so dude is definitely is is there any
alternative to H5 or G5 or is that those
are the two candidate moves I guess
yeah also if I wanted to trick you I
could play H5 King G7 G5 and G5 Knight
G5 and we are where I want to be but uh
in the right order so
it's worth it because you want like to
play G5 this this you would prefer over
that other line probably
well I just think if I play Knight D2
and I can get my knight to F5 I'm so
happy with that
because you're defending head six Pawn
will is a problem you can never solve
you can exchange my bishop and you're
still stuck with that one
and you'll be defending it your whole
game soon
circus face kind of says it all here
do those okay the minister of defense
let's see what he does
I wonder if the
the games with Sam shook his confidence
a little bit in terms of defensive skill
I I understand it's not doesn't really
work like that but
do you think he's able to put it behind
him completely or does that maybe
subconsciously make him
second guess himself and then certain
key
situations
my only feeling is when I survive a tie
break my confidence recovers as well
maybe there's something annoying at them
but I mean once he had once he survived
that match he had to feel good about
himself and the next match went so good
for him it's hard to believe his
confidence is still affected
right
yeah pretty one-sided with a Sam and
speaking of finite let's check into his
game because
stuff is happening
and
C5 and you find you remove Bishop D2
uh okay
so antidote against CD and now here
comes the F1
looks like black I mean instinctively I
guess black has to play F5 or
because if you allow a fight that Heads
Will Roll
foreign
C1 and queen C6
yeah no no no this is not serious I
agreeing
so what does black do
you see too late to ask that question is
is uh Bishop B4 and F5 really it's all
it's over maybe it is we should be full
I might see five and F5 might just be
resolved
right
it should be five yeah EF5 Knight F5 is
hopeless and a bishop e56 at least is
very strong
all right it's not even rookie one
gosh this is a disaster
you know
yeah what is what is the most political
movie I wonder
where is the knockout
yeah just review one
and a bishop
yeah still Bishop C5 Bishop D6 yeah so I
guess just here well
and
[Music]
like praise and I got praise to the Gods
but the other question is how is black
ever going to get out
oh yeah no that's maybe bishop C2 and
King gate is a plan or something but
he's basically maybe he's stuck with
that Rook on h8
I mean this looks like only one side is
playing no casting chess
right
yeah or or white could do this
Bishop D6 and now Pro which is Bishop
takes D4
I would imagine apparently the computer
is like actually instead of FX E6
instead of f take C6 I could have
started with little ke1 not to commit uh
F takes C6 just rookie one after Bishop
e51
oh yeah because if Bishop D6
I was hoping that Rook takes these six
might work but maybe it doesn't
wow
maybe nice you might have
yes maybe that's enough Knight E6 and
thing order
fe6 or physics
not it's not worth trying this right
right yeah
so let's see what he's done
he has played Knight B6
might be six
oh
and of course reinforcing the pressure
on D4
he's only threat potentially threatening
to take it with a rook even though that
doesn't seem to be a huge threat
but if I go to Casey one here
ah Rook takes D4 Bishop E3 Bishop takes
E5 they might have just enough
compensation left
oh
aha
so how to defend that pawn
okay so there there maybe bishop C3 just
lengthening my Pawn chain a bit
Knight D5
and
could we take
F5
three
Queen F4
thank you at five
well if you take on F5 I take twice and
I play D5 right G5 yeah
but not F1
but then Bishop B6
now Rook F1 and after D5 db6
so what's your number sorry
uh Knight F5 Knight F5 bishop f55 and
the zombies yeah
even and I can play G4 and Bishop C4 and
A4 and you know it's just uh but there's
some C4 Bishop D string oh no maybe not
one time yeah no no I'd start with
Bishop C4
right so there's no discovery and then
I'll play G4 and uh try to put
very hard no and Bishop C3 has been
played yeah
and I think Philadelphia is you know
he's going to play quickly here he's
this is very frustrating to play against
Magnus now there's also Bishop C3 Knight
T5 maybe you could I mean it's painful
to give up such a bishop but
perhaps you could also do this
and I don't see whether black and I mean
it looks a little bit iffy but somehow
again CD is never possible so
I think this might just be also winning
but I can go I can't play Queen G5
that's not good but what if I go
King G8 F6 Queen f8 is that really what
I want to do
okay let's throw it in clicking j8
all right I think you're going to play
yeah and then okay we should do there's
Rick D4 so that doesn't work yet
oh wait a minute it takes takes
what about 92
well I was hoping that G5 ah but then
you take a knight F4 even no okay it
doesn't work right
or Rook F4 here also
and then drop the queen back something
like this
enjoy life for a bit
yeah White's life is very good
so I think either of those options in
the event of Knight D5
it's lack of Alternatives here
it's too late to even consider
F5 obviously now with the fun C3 white
one Passat
by the way um we don't have to switch to
it but in sergey's game G5 hg5 and H25
display
so Jan I think took very quickly without
considering those ideas of H5
interestingly enough as we check the two
board View
and it appears that Bishop C3 for Sergey
might be the only chance to stay in the
game
um
let's have a look Bishop E7
what happens if Knight E5
King G7
yeah King G7 I guess is the idea
we're gonna wait for it to update
G5 HGH super should be seven has
happened
hmm
as we check
a full board camera right here
and here's the current position
this also seems like a pretty resilient
defense
it's not so easy to infiltrate
I mean if you play 95 King 27 and then
F4
thank you
black can hardly move right
right
maybe Rook C7
then if you move
but how is white going at like King F3
what is White's long-term plan here I've
Improvement is it usually looking at
freaking G4 E4 F5 I mean you these moves
I've seen them even in positions where
um you have equal material on the king
side let's say three versus three and
then white get the Rook on D7 and plays
F4 G5 H4 black has King G7 and F7 G6 H7
and still it's
it's uh endless suffering
right okay
what's he doing he's gone rookie five
Rook E5 so he opens The Bishop's
diagonal
Rocky yeah but okay his idea is in
Knight C6 he wants to play Rook B5 and
then slam on B7 no what does he want to
do for Knight C6 right are you looking
for maybe yeah
oh this is something crazy what about
rookie7 immediately
ah
you're right 95
Bishop G5 Knight G6 or something yeah
this looks very appetizing
indeed I mean I don't know if it's
necessary but this might just be sort of
show stopper also Knight F7 I think
it's Knight F7 Rook H7 95 or H7 is
threatened
so
this does look
pretty much like game over so if not
Knight C6 then what does black do
where does that go rookie eight is that
no that doesn't look possible
move the bishop to A3
or before just keep this diagonal
mm-hmm
now
okay five there's Bishop's ah maybe Rook
A5 and 95 something like that
you have to go back here right
and
wow so many appetizing options
five
okay this is King G7 Maybe
but so many options here look look good
already at this point
but probably the bishop has to be moved
right
wow
or maybe you don't see steps
foreign
and now
if Knight D4 then you still want to go
Knight C6
um
your roxy7 seems pretty robust
at least for the moment
well then let me go rookie Rook hit
rookie for
eign
yes because if you double counter double
on the H file I'll win F7 in the end
if I counter double as in but at this
point already
you might not know what you're saying
no then I go okay
how to catch one and if you go uh ah you
can't even do it okay because then the
bishop yeah everything is collapsing and
if you're okay immediately then
I mean sub technique is still required
but uh White is completely winning
obviously
so
this is um
this is this is a potential disaster
rookie five is a really nice move
I still don't like it I must say
but what do you feel like practically
accurate I just thought Knight if I have
Forest right no it does look very cool
it does look very awkward it is again it
steals the night square but
I just play F4 then I go King F3 G4 then
I go E4 it already can't stop F5 I mean
this is the most natural plant I thought
right
I think maybe but okay even if I might
work let's see
surrogate with 16 minutes now for 17
moves which is not helping his cause
and
I think one more slight inaccuracy and
the game right and by the way in Carlson
to save they are following that line
with f593
um but we'll get to that in a moment
let's
keep an eye on karyakan in the meantime
all right I guess we can switch to the
timer
for the moment to the I'm going to say
again
and eventually I think you
had we're calculating this line and you
you mentioned Queen F3
well I put it on F4 I have no particular
reason to not put it on F3 but
mm-hmm
and then just takes takes
wow
complete disaster
complete disaster for black
yeah we have this position
allowing your Rook D7 by the way oh here
we go all right now we gotta get back to
the scan
potential
okay
so if you see I wonder if seven then
we're in business
I wonder if this was his initial idea or
if he intended simply rookie four or or
you found your Rook B5
I don't know but he's got it
he's got to see it
and then the question how convincing is
it actually winning or is it just much
better
well it's a pawn and a winning position
so if you if I take on G6 you cannot
stop me taking on f8 I think
and then I still can clear up one on the
queen side I have two versus one and
your king is stuck your king and Rook
will be stuck defending F7
that seems the easiest Knight F7 might
work as well let's just if you put the
moves on the board we'll say Rook D7
95.95 I guess you're going to take on G5
yeah because otherwise Knight 20 G6 so
you take and now I have Knight takes F7
first of all I'm threatening Knight G5
check look at 7 mate so you have to take
it
so yeah you have to take that right
and then I play Rook F7 and then you've
got to go King h8 because you don't want
to deal with discoveries and then I go
Rook takes B7 yes
it's already I think you cannot defend
both Upon Us you'll lose one of them
right because A6 work B6 and A5
no probably not Rook B5 but
yeah well A5
F4 King F3 you know the usual stuff so
it's this has got to be
winning
um
I wonder if Sergey Sark is on what he
has in mind against because it can't be
this position
hmm
d8 and I've solved a hell of a lot
right
B7 just looks massive
so in this position
is there nothing other than Bishop takes
G5 yeah Rook C8 Knight G6 is decided
using this pen yeah not that pen
maybe some trick
but there's nothing
to G6 also looks effortlessly winning to
me so Rook D7 was very strong
number eight
after
seven
I'm trying to go Rook C7
can I go Rook back to D5
I mean let's take a step here black
played Knight B8
so that uh The Rook on D1 could not The
Rook on D5 could not go to D7
and now we have accomplished that The
Rook on D1 jumped over the Rook on D5
and landed on B7 essentially
there's no way this is equal
so
yeah this
but where is maybe I'll play rookie 4
also because
um if you play Knight A5 then I can even
clamp with Bishop D5
um memory oxy segment here
yeah Big Steaks and I have to deliver a
knockout which I don't see but um Rick
D7 played
well I also think you might play Bishop
d8 actually he might play Bishop d8 so
let's see I mean Rook uh Bishop David
yeah sorry it's all it's entirely
possible that he is also overlooked us I
mean
I wouldn't rule it out it seems like
correct and it's kind of relaying from
the last couple of moves and apparently
dude doesn't have a vegan curry acting
with white in any format so
this would be a first and what a first
it would be so what about Rook E5 to D5
okay
Rook C7 just takes in Rook D7 it's over
for this one
if Bishop C7
what are you threatening you're not
threatening anything so I go Knight
hitch four
yeah the F4 right
and if King King F4
then F4
and if I go now
yes
for dear life here
[Music]
I feel like in this position
but who knows
broadcast seven almost in such positions
but no
um
yeah rooft5 Bishop C7
black is now threatening to take of
course right because in the end there's
Rook c7s
[Music]
so
white must react to that
okay so Bishop B8
what should we play
I mean there's something to be said for
rugby five just lengthening this uh
seventh rank
mm-hmm
V6 induce it
and then maybe 95
.
yeah just simplify because if I play F4
you're stuck with this
phone on F7 for the rest of the game
yeah this seems really nice
uh Sergey
continues to think he's definitely
weighing
the option of Bishop d8 against taking
and
if you take you by force reach that
position down upon so I think Bishop B8
is
definitely the more
resilient defensive move or so it
appears
probably he missed it up
yeah
it one gets that impression for sure
given given the amount of time that he's
thinking and as he's thinking we're
going to take this opportunity to go on
a quick break Sergey karyakin
has his back against the wall firmly
yeah is
very very close to winning the World's
Cup the suspense is on don't go anywhere
we'll be back in a few with more World
Cup action you're watching the finals
[Music]
thank you foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
worlds cop you're watching Finals game
two the games are well underway and we
might have two decisive results today
um and if Duda is able to convert this
big Advantage he will emerge the World's
Cup winner let's quickly check into the
Carlson game against fedes
a couple of things have happened Magnus
uh going for a queen F3 and Bishop you
were proposing Queen F4 and for the sake
of taking on F5
yeah well I realized that after Knight
F5 I don't need to take on F5 I can play
D5
and so maybe that was magnus's point
so maybe it's good for that reason so
because uh if you go Knight take G3 I
can interpolate D6
and if my queen had been on F4 then you
would have 92 checks so that's the
difference
can I go Rook D6 here
oh
Bishop D6
um but it's not worth allowing yeah then
then you have actually Rook presets
right
take on F5
Maybe
okay
Knight F1 I guess
by the way Magnus is taken on F5 so
Okay Okay so we've decided and here I'm
not entirely sure who the staff should
take with the bishop
perhaps thinking with a point no no yeah
the difference here is you have BFI
because uh after D5 you can actually
take on E5 whereas with the queen on F4
you could that was my reasoning so and
that's that's actually after year five
he might just be playing some quiet move
like Rook A1 but he's played Bishop F5
instantly and magnus's responded with Z5
what can I tell you
that's a bit surprising
to see you have an idea there on this
position you see
also he could be disappointed as a
position for so long you're not thinking
that rationally you're just making some
moves and things so
um
right particularly
right
and um I move like C4 here
and if it should be
six
question no but yeah Bishop B6 oh look
at this bishop B6 or F2 Maybe yeah and
Bishop C5 then
no then you can have like that no but
then you play because then they play and
B6 and you're winning yeah okay okay
no D6 doesn't win Sonic there's a Pawn
on C4 I forgot I can't play I was going
to jump and play Bishop takes Z6 and use
the pin oh there's a Pawn on C4 now no
but but maybe G4 immediately
ah
I agree G6
G6
yeah
gfgf and I get it establishing yeah I
get a jail Rook on j8 I should be
somewhat happy I think with this really
cool idea
and if I
yeah but maybe I should take
yes but membership takes Queen F6
ah you're my roots okay somehow
I don't go for your Bishop at all at all
but
okay it doesn't work what does
Rook D5
yeah it seems to be winning somehow
so this is after D5 C4 currently better
say I was thinking
in this position
there's some stuff going on here it's
the game is not over Bishop could Bishop
B6 be played
and if I go
assuming I believe you when I go Bishop
C4 what are you doing exactly
I was thinking of
V5 dare I say wait a minute maybe Rook
D5
ah but Bishop D5 C4 F2 yes no this
doesn't work
I forgot Network F2
otherwise of course could make more I
mean you could play 85 but then I go
Queen takes F5 B Tech C4 E6 and that's
going to be curtains
yep I'm just going to warm your way in
for example to G6 and pretty much I mean
I would even say okay one and
just what about
green age for first Maybe
ah
that is awkward D6 now day six wins
T6
and I don't have Bishop takes E6 again
I'm walking into this
but no G phones but Bishop E6
that's what you're going to say fun
sorry
oh that is lovely
so maybe Queen F4 is better because
there's no more this queen H4 check move
I don't do so
that's the one
I told you
should be six is a nasty little move and
somehow this Canon G1 experiences
discomfort
this guy is he's done it
oh
watch this match go into a tapering
what to do with white
can white prophylactically play workout
too
what about G4
uh then Bishop b3d64 check was your
problem right
and of D6 does C4 check
Aha and okay so this position I can also
go to D6 but then again
D6 and then uh C4 check and queen D7 and
but it should be winning for white
anyway
oh I know how King moves
yes
there's got to be something in this
position though
maybe just recap too
wait can I can just uh blundered
wow I don't think he act as the designs
what
did he play Knight F5
he didn't take on d8 what
no way
did he not go work to see
I cannot believe this he's going to be
55 I mean it's probably still winning
wait but if I play A6 how are you
winning I just took B1 a rugby four
would be one yeah Ruby four and Rook F4
okay it's still winning but what's can
you believe that no but if I go Rooks
after Bishop D5 if I go wrong you will
take on no you can't then wait put it
just put it one second uh Rook C7 after
Bishop D5 if you take on d8 and you take
on AFA now I play B6 and A6 and I win
your Bishop on D5
but I just I can't wrap my head around
how how you cannot take on the eight
here yeah it's literally I mean I I
don't usually say this but it is
incredibly obvious
this is insane
Rook C7 has been played
but but uh sure that is what happened I
mean there were no moves that added in
Queen
Yeah because sometimes that happens in
the transition perhaps we can confirm
because I okay Doda is still winning he
can play Bishop takes F7 check now and
it's still over so there is no no harm
done he can play Bishop takes F7 and now
it's over
it appears that that is indeed what
happened we're going to
I mean his position is that good that he
doesn't even need to play the winning
moves yeah this happened Knight A5
okay and let me just show really quickly
why so rip takes the eight if Rook takes
D then you take the Knight and it's over
and if Knight takes B3
then of course you take the Rook NFA
with check and then the Knight on B3 is
lost so I wonder if Duda has realized
that
well actually after the
while they were after Bishop D5 it was
kariakin who went down like this so it's
almost like he saw it a second late and
he thought oh my God I survived that
rather than Duda saying it yet
right I think Bishop F7 check is still
winning so there is no problem here
so Bishop F7 King G7
yes and then um
Rook takes C7
seven and then Bishop I don't know E6
Bishop D5 is winning I mean and 94 is
coming so it's just came over
right well this should be six Maybe
then I go Knight E5 and I go F4
all right back to back to uh the
original
yeah and then G6 is gonna fall no this
is this is completely I mean I thought
this position was good with an F7 bot
but if you remove the F7 opponents it's
getting too awesome
yeah and Duda with plenty of time he
played instantly this move Bishop D5
which is it's not something you see very
often there there he goes so he's going
to take he's taking Bishop F7 so it's
okay it's good he paused now because
yeah he sort of gathered himself and
yeah there comes the pawn and
well barring a miracle we're going to
see yeah
winning this game and becoming the World
Cup champion and he is the he will be
the first call
to make it to the candidates I believe
which is yeah but either back two days
back so right that is true
that is true and girls I mean when the
World Cup is still uh by jawana and
that's huge what he did so
yeah
oh yeah and rather cunningly he beat
kayaking in the decisive in the second
game because beating him in the first
doesn't seem to be enough but uh
right as as Sam Shanklin can report
has had an absolutely incredible run
and he wins the World Cup with just a
incredibly smooth effort
what a performance I'm astounded he
might have missed Rook takes d8 but that
does not detract in the least he beats
Magnus he beats carjackin
and um
in regular games so that's quite
something
right and and the confidence of drawing
with black
he didn't seem to be in trouble
essentially a single time this
tournament
what an incredible performance by the
young man from fallens
he's had such an amazing chess career
and this result portends
many many more successes in the future
huge congrats younger stuff did it is
the winner of the 2021 payday Worlds Cup
now we have one game still going
Magnus against fedes and
I think magnus's
potentially botched it a little bit
let's see this is the position on the
board
it seemed a lot more winning earlier
what to make of this position
is this still going to work out to work
out one maybe
four
oh Bishop G4
yeah your photograph two
yeah
and let's say 24
you can just start collecting
yeah yeah I mean of course this should
be when you work out of one
and um
how about G6 preparing Bishop F5
um
maybe already some tactics
yeah I mean there's there's a lot of
stuff here
I feel like oh you know what there might
be
here here
I don't know forget it I was gonna
suggest some crazy Queen sack but
nah but man that just looks like
something's got to manifest itself I can
even take on F7 Maybe
yeah maybe Rook up seven
and after workout seven or cup seven
King F7
let's play
staircase
Queen's the eight B7
yeah
and then claim that Bishop A6 wins no
it's made it's made I think I think it's
made because what you do is you go there
they're there and then look we need to
checks yeah
this is exactly how the game is gonna
end
um
so we went pretty far no no they're
they're only after Rook D7 Magna system
Magnus has really been
sluggish
in this game he's got about 11 minutes
for
10 moves
so
but but I guess it's quite easy to play
here with white just double the Rooks
and eventually something is going to
give yeah so okay
yes still thinking is Magnus
it doesn't seem too happy as to how
things unfolded here
yeah
so it doesn't matter
right
so trying to find the most precise
continuation
yeah I mean at some point I think I
think this queen up four moment was was
actually crucial going out for it was
probably winning
um quite a bit more quickly but of
course as you pointed out I mean F2 now
still doesn't spoil anything so yeah
yeah it's winning
I don't really understand why Magnus is
oh maybe you can even play A4 here A4
and A5 and A6 and open up the thing to
see the twin in I will go if yeah okay
and but also those fixes this fixes the
ponds so maybe this is good
independently yes
so
something Magnus is really like he is
taking a very long think he's below 10
minutes
and
he's just not making a decision here
there there he goes I think it's gonna
be okay too
the queen of Queen E2
ah he wants to he wants to sack on a
five I think
if Bishop G4 what does he do queen E4
I suppose so and after Queen F5 a queen
H5
yeah that's kind of similar to what we
looked at yes but the the obvious
question is why why not Rook A2 or Rook
F2 and then after Bishop G4 he go to E4
straight away
right why why was he a friendly Bishop
record or something
um this should be four also what about
Queen G4 here how bad is it exactly
we need to Queen G4 let's say
there
yeah I don't know
Queenie 2 is a very odd nerve
you know of course it's Magnus but
it's still it's still an odd move
yeah
can he take Photoshop H5 and Life Starts
untangling
there he goes I think he's gonna go
pinch before
I think Magnus missed it like just
grimacing
yeah the technique here has not been not
been good for not been great for Magnus
I mean at least that's the impression it
gives right
right
Queenie too I just I cannot wrap my head
around that move it just seems like he's
in this particular instance he's playing
for sort of one move
one move threats
what is the one movement
yeah yeah
I forgot it for a second
yeah but
if and queen C4 there it is
okay yeah
wow
so what exactly does white even do here
how does I preserve an advantage
how about turning to the end game like
takes takes or cut four
Bishop H5
yeah I was thinking something like
you're okay F1
then I can play Maybe G5 or am I just
asking for a second all right Play
Bishop G6 then I play H5 then I try to
get H4
it's an extra Pawn that's all I mean
there's a two extra pounds it's got to
be worth something
apparently Rook takes F5 is winning
anyway after after Queen G4
yep I considered that but I wasn't sure
after Queen E2 Bishop E2 EF5 how strong
it was but he just go back can you
continue as if nothing happened right I
guess it's just totally totally winning
yeah okay no I just think ing of that
but
I it didn't feel very real so
yeah I'm sure I think Magnus like
notices this but I wonder if he's gonna
go for it because again like he doesn't
want this going to tie break
on the other hand is white really even
risking in a position like this
I don't think no he is no
I think he's going to do it I mean
so maybe
better than Queen G4
talking from black person there it is
okay no hesitation
and one very important detail is after
workout five between YouTube it should
be two C4 you have Rook F2 so but I
can't even get oh even if you doubted it
would be winning but just
something
and if Queen F5 then recap one is
accelerating even Black's demise
yeah this will be over in just a couple
of moves it seems
and um
yeah queen of five
and a queen G5 for example
I guess Bishop D2 we'll send it off
okay say it again you're fine sorry
any moves basically
yeah oh he does take I think Vladimir
wants to see this gay man's name
yeah this is just completely winning
but what does The Knockout blow idea so
you were saying you're fine here here
here in our work after it no I said
queen I'm sorry oh Queen after sorry I'm
losing my mind
and
he had soil paralysis is the threat to
play Bishop Bishop B5 news
right although again you have to watch
you have to watch your C4
Magnus is about to move Bishop D2
he wants that Queen out of there
this might Simply Be resigns very very
shortly
because if the queen has to move then
white screen maybe moves into G4
yeah very similar to yesterday's game I
mean talking about the mentioned that
half piece down but no counter play at
all
wow
yeah we saw some other very nice
exchange cyclists tournament on trying
to remember
in an earlier round at all
think about that so if Queen H4 against
Rook F4 is the idea
and if Queen d8 Bishop do you think
Queen G4 is the fastest or is there
something
looks huge because you can the queen
wants to be there the whole time because
then I can even go to F3 G3 I can go
Bishop E1 to switch four there's so many
nice ideas
so after Bishop DT if you go Queen H4 I
guess I'm gonna play Rook F4 kick it out
and then go Queen G4 and I can always
regroup
right
it looks effortless I feel that
nonetheless he should have taken on E2
and I've taken on F5 and if that's lost
it's lost but uh
giving leaving the Queens on the board
doesn't seem to help black no no
this um
I'm gonna say I might simply resign
as well because against Magnus you're
not you're not surviving this and
oh and there's there's really cool lines
that happen there's fireworks
after something like recap 16 each time
I was just entertaining myself with
um Rook H6 j6 check yeah Queen G6 check
oh that's even more beautiful but take
Stakes here
we should be here
this is slightly winning
wow that's beautiful queen G6 and
if King G8 you can probably
well like in uh
take on you don't have to do anything
there's no threat I take on E6 with the
Rook
wait but I take you think then I go to
F6 check
and
I know then you actually have requests
okay then I go to play exception but
anyway okay we were having fun yeah
magnus's Magnus has gone 24.
we are expecting resignation any second
Rook F6 let's see if
what does black do I mean I thought Rick
H7
we need to just remind everybody he has
been unbeaten in the entire world cup
and uh
nothing yet wow that is amazing I lost
in a tie break and that was only
repeated three times camski 2007 svidler
in 2011 and and kramnik in 2013 were
also unbeaten I'm surprised that that
that's happened more more times than I
thought and young should stop dinner
joins a very elite list of names
um who have remained unbeaten tie breaks
classical
oh a six played it's exactly what
Venezuela does
will Carlson resist Rick G6
workout sticks rather
or will he play Magnus mover F3
you've got to play around F6 there also
Rook F6 there's a problem with Rook
takes D6 right
oh
so you might not want to go there
that is a missable tactic though
but not by highness of course
can you play Bishop B6 no I guess not
the evil bar doesn't like it
you know I guess patience is
you can see Queen E6 Queen G6 and then
E6 but then I would like my Bishop on C3
to start with rather than D2 but right
maybe winning anyway
yeah I wonder what the fast
seven
Bishop B1 Bishop H4 but I'm a 10 25
.
somehow it's not
amazingly not quite as easy as I would
have like as one would think but of
course
yeah
we have seven recap seven and now
Queenie six
and I'll pack it in with Queen juice six
now this is over I think
it's more
97. what about Queen E7
I think that's I think that's even
more convince
check this line out
here
uh and now I was thinking I don't know
what am I saying
where's the one here Bishop F7 yeah
Queen F7 though
I guess black is in white is in no hurry
we can just chill with Queen takes B7
but okay maybe it's not worth going for
Magnus he's calculating and he's got six
and a half minutes
maybe he's not quite seeing anything
that he finds convincing enough
apparently Rook F7 is the best
well he must be looking at it but
thinking well do I really want to go
through go ahead with that or can I just
make some more quick moves
that's how it goes
of course if I had played A4 and A5 and
you put your Bishop on A7 in the
beginning then now Rook F7 would win
easily because I could just finish with
D7 but I think that's right
you know what I could do I could take an
F7 take on E6 you go Queen f8 and then I
just play Queen B5 and you have no
defense to E6
oh I could play Queen G6 and you have no
defense to E6 as well
right
I think in fact that's the simplest
because the your queen your king is
trapped so now E6 will
this is a great funny position
s where the bishop ah yeah D7 and uh
eight and capture the Rock
8758 Queen E8
and Bishop takes F7 right and it's over
and queen E8
he's gonna take on F7
yes
um
yeah this game
will end very very soon but you find
when you know it's very very late for
you so we don't want to keep you
um
so it's
um entirely your choice this game might
last though for for a couple more moves
and
you know you have a very tough schedule
so
um
I'll give you the uh I'll give you the
the choice to find way
we're always happy for you to stay but
but don't feel pressured if if uh if you
have to take off
yeah that's sweet Daniel yeah but
probably I need to run for repairs it's
like 11 10 years of course
but I'll follow the resort inside I
guess this game will finish very soon
yeah and I think most of it has been
decided but uh this will mean of course
that there are no time breaks tomorrow
and you if Yvonne's been a absolute
pleasure and an honor to commentate with
you all these days
um and all of your Insight and uh
professionalism is much appreciated so I
know uh the fans
all appreciate you as well so thank you
you fun uh for all the commentary it's
been a pleasure we will go on a quick
break and
when we come back uh Michigan I will
finish watching as Carlson most likely
will defeat Vladimir fedesaf to round
off this year's World Cup thank you
Yvonne and have a great night and uh we
will be back on the other side of the
break
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the World Cup and we see
Vladimir having taken on F7 or the king
this game about to reach its conclusion
Magnus checking on F5 here
and Vichy will he go for this maybe
Queen G6 and V6 where is The Knockout
blow the champions
so boom boom boom boom
and uh I don't see uh how is clinching
right well so maybe here Bishops
but let's say I go ev7
G6
right
and I have to go Bishop d8 because I can
never play H5 otherwise but after Bishop
d8 I'm playing H5 H4 and I might bring
my Rook out that way
right via vh5
it'll survive the apocalypse
I mean you can play G4 H5
I was thinking about that G5 oh you can
play G3 H5 King H2 H4 G4 or something
but I feel it won't be in time anyway
and if I get one page three then there
are too many squares for group and you
doesn't work so I'm not sure let's see
what Magnus says Queen G6 this is the
way to finish it let's see how he
finishes I think Bishop C3 maybe
something like on a hurried because
or
yes so Queen just I can even play yeah
Queen G6 King f8
what he's gonna repeat to get to move
40.
what moves it now it's move 39 so
White's about to make his 40th move
and Magnus gets like Wayne G6 check
and he's gotten up I'm not sure
or my apologies no this is move let's
see
no this is this is move 40 has been
played this is our this is move 41. okay
so probably needed to use the restroom
but somehow when it gets the sense that
yeah we were thinking Bishop E6 is much
easier
Bishop P6 Queen G6 and Bishop D7
and E6 yeah
very surprising the Magnus oh I guess
he's going he went for the tempting line
all right
yeah this was more natural one but um
foreign
yeah by the way move 40 has been played
and those those people thinking that
Magnus is only two minutes he does not
have only two minutes uh the way these
clocks work when you come down to zero
when time control is made 30 minutes is
added automatically to both sides so it
will the clock will come down to zero
and then it will replenish 30 minutes
so that's the definition of
that's the definition of you know a move
being made 30 minutes are added to your
clock
okay
so where is The Knockout blow
and I guess the first question is do we
give another check on G6
it's not entirely clear
I can't even see what Black's threat is
here quite just improves this position
somehow
foreign
this is crazy like I actually don't see
the direct way to win
it's somehow
it's not as clinical as you would expect
from Magnus right
right
yeah I mean he's normally
crunching these sort of things and here
it seems that closing it is not that
easy for him
yeah it usually doesn't allow this and
he doesn't make that kind of a Precision
in the critical moments
I mean if you think we go back to G6
Queen G6 check I think I now have it
worked out so Queen G6 checking f8
E6
Queen F6 87 if you do that
foreign
yes uh King hitch two
okay so black has only one source of
trying to free myself oh I see which
wait a minute
and now
H5
King H3
H4 or I can throw in A4 if I want it
doesn't matter but maybe so King H3 H4
and then I go King G4
I have to try this perhaps
and Rook H4
oh sorry I forgot you actually have
cleared a square for your Rook
no then I have to go Bishop E2 and then
try to slowly uh basically say that you
have no moves ever and uh
but at some moment I learned to collect
the pawn on the queen side and at that
moment your Rook will jump
so it's not as clean as I would like but
or if you can try to dislodge this
bishop I mean this G5 square is very
hard to access somehow
no wait wait we had
somehow I need to get in King G4 H3
Bishop G5 and just wrap it up
yeah
I'll always have uh maybe put the bishop
on D5 because you have a G2 otherwise
I'm winning you have hg2 but so that's
maybe that's why I put the bishop here
because yeah
King G4
and then Rook H5 then Rook H5
at which point
oh okay try oh yeah yeah yeah
I forgot that we have to keep the bishop
on E2
wow
it's amazing how how not relatively not
easy this is
and so how does black Shuffle yeah I
mean we're trying to find a mathematical
win I suspect it's just winning but
we're trying to find something
mathematical and that's going to be hard
so right but where is is black and Zeus
on here how does like let's say we just
move back and forth
hmm
and Bishop F6 I guess
or B5
but b5a4 I mean something's going to
materialize
yes
well you can play B5
and therefore you play C4
what if I go Bishop E3
C4
and I oh no that doesn't work either wow
okay so I take it and the idea by the
way is that Bishop C4 then Rook H5
Magnus has gone back to G6 this might
happen
I was thinking Bishop A7 Bishop Anthony
unrealistic
and we're about to see if Magnus
well at least Federal saves moves are
easy so right
you could just watch Magnus agonize over
the decision I mean once you get to this
point you feel relieved because you
think well you find a win or you don't
but it's not my thing and uh
right black as black is an easy life
you're relatively speaking Yeah
we had a good tournament and his last
three rounds have been tough but
um
very
yeah yeah
incredibly enough so we're back to this
position
you know actually I got it I go E6 Queen
F6 take take everything to Bishop d8
and then the way to clamped you is
Bishop E2
Bishop E2 all right well let me embark
on you have to go there and then I'm
gonna bring my king to the Queen's side
and leave my Bishop on G4 that way the
clamp never goes away so I go King F1
and I'm gonna win with my king and if
you play H4 I go Bishop G4 and the clamp
stays so the only thing you can do is to
play Rook hit six but I I suspect that
should be like
because I'll bring my King around and I
it'll be winning just somehow
yeah and and let's say exactly winning
black is almost oh my goodness Black is
Black isn't so going to you even need to
bring it no black does not have a single
move after H3 GH3 I have my clunks too
nothing has changed so now I'll go back
King E2 King D3 and then I'll go King E4
D5 or something and then the moment
Bishop F6 happens you have this
even King D3 I don't see I mean I can do
it slowly but of course you're right I
can believe but anything yeah it's
incredible or or
um
if Bishop B6 then Bishop G5 so either
direction results in that's made there
should be some Bishop Basics
that is a fourth twin so Rook H6 has to
be tried
yeah and then it's uh straightforward
you just take big
you leave a bishop on F5 or H5 and then
you walk the king over and
slowly but surely you will collect the
bonds and you can still go to C8 after
you've cleaned up there right and The
Bishop's never in danger the king can
never capture it because of G7 and the
pawns are never a serious Force to
contend with faith there is just no way
to hold this so right
yeah Magnus definitely
yeah
he's got 24 minutes he's about to move
it seems
there he goes okay here we are so Bishop
E2 G4 and it's game over that's a Magnus
like conversion there going to an end
game and it seems like it allows chances
but in reality it's very forcing after
ed7 is Black forced to yeah
right walking up one here I thought king
of fun is actually important
what is the only move right but yes
right right exactly
okay Queen F6 played and here we go
we're about to see all of this
actually it isn't I can play Bishop E3
Queen E3 King H2 and I think that's
winning
with him in which position after Queen
D4 check Queen episode
okay this is just showing off so
huh that's a lot that's amazing
up to too many meters
and there he goes ed7 Queen F6 all of
this happens
and for the sale for Bishop d8
and now Bishop P2 is actually very
pretty
um yeah I mean you can start looking at
one H5 it should be two but basically H4
Bishop G4 and the Builder still should
and the good thing about these positions
is that there's very little to calculate
once you find the mechanism there should
be six
maybe same thing he wants to Bishop on
G4 ah of course
that's even nicer yeah
because he the king doesn't even have to
waste a move uh you can just click but
okay this is over right should I say
everyone's um
should I say we'll play H5 quickly but
um the moment the pawn gets stage four
it's very important to prevent Rook H5
with Bishop too far
alternatively oh yeah yeah
there's many winning ideas there you
could also walk your king up to F5 and
go Bishop G5
but
yes Magnus will 2-0 for the seven very
convenient okay there were some blips on
there
you know in the conversion but by and
large I'm very impressed with magnus's
recovery from the dude I'm actually
really put some passion into this match
one gets the sense at least
he's waiting for the inevitable to
happen
there comes H5
I think once Bishop G4 has played I
think he will resign it so
right
King is about to walk up
H4 Bishop G4
also it's nice they didn't even bother
with King h2h3 and all that stuff he
right away he he saw that the correct
way to do it was the bishop so you can
see this uh Clarity yeah Bishop G4 and I
think that's sister yeah it's a complete
plus size minus Carlson yeah
I oh sorry he went to pick up a pawn I
thought he was going to stop the clock
right me too
but no
he faked you out
it's over and there's nothing no stale
Matrix nope no past Pawns
moves and Magnus will probably gain
race classical
yeah I would imagine
sure he beat let's not forget
it is undefeated in the classical so he
is
he lost
yeah you choose your own book row you
two zero Atari is that is that a new
world uh
I'm not just a commentator
um one and a half half white tashek
also wow so Magnus actually played
incredibly
and then he no he just said it is one
one uh one one Duda he he only lost
yellow points to the polls
right and one one with Jesse Pinko as
well
so yeah three type breaks
Oh Oh I thought he beat right to check
on the classical but no no you're right
you're right it was it was a tie break
yeah yeah
the Polish players really really did a
number on him
so
B5 played by a bit of save
he's going to drink the
cup to its Bitter End
and the king is walking up inexorably
toward D5
slouching toward Bethlehem
there it is
I was thinking of picking E3 just to go
to E4 directly but I realized that I'm
really silly to allow who gets this oh
okay she's saying yeah
yeah then the game begins a new
probably you can still hold the
or maybe I mean I can go over here by
fighting E4 and and then play Bishop G4
kick it but okay it'll be quite careless
right
time for Vladimir to stop the clock and
Carlson is gaining we are being told by
uh by back 5.4 yellow points which for
magnus's
I mean that's a sizable
that's a sizable game
but crazy for how many games he won I
mean it I mean he beats for the Seth
twice and he's still only gaining
you know Five Points
yeah can't relate
all right
maybe B form but
abcb
no I'm trying to think about what is for
the same even thinking like why
what is it that he could be aiming for
here
he's looking at the clock like should I
stop it now or like smoke
I guess this is before this game is
getting five so right about six points
he's going to be gaining
but again I didn't know I can imagine
how Fidelity feels if you lose
you're doing well and then you lose uh
the second game of the semis which means
there's no comeback then you have a rest
day to think about it then you lose two
more so
well then you find out you're playing
Magnus
and you find out you have no chance to
make it into the cabinets because Duda
beat Carlson with black
that's got to be an excruciating moment
watching that tie break for FedEx of
course he would have had to be
Sergey but
or be The Duda rather but
yeah who is who has been playing out of
his absolutely
right I'm far from it given that we do
this has been playing
but um Vladimir did have an interesting
path I mean he didn't play anybody over
26.40
uh before kayaking and doesn't diminish
at all from his performance obviously
but
it might have been a jarring
um oh and a funny uh funny little stat
here all these moves 48 moves in and for
the sales refinish it hasn't moved yet
and white made sure of that by putting
the bishop
what's that
apparently feder saves Rook on h8 does
not move the entire game
okay like it's sit on a chain
never a great sign
okay Magnus is conflicting you for
slightly dragging
A5 King B3 A5 keeps it simple
three and then
resigns
and I think that is simply resigned
without awaiting magnus's next move
and the World Cup 2021 is over the last
move is King E4 Magnus Carlson the world
champion is the third place winner
um and then a a stellar it would be an
understatement a superb one should say
performance by the world champion
that is not reflected in you know the
expectations that are always put in
front of him but if you think about his
actual results they were very impressive
he once again reaffirms
that he is in great form he's capable of
defeating virtually any super GM on
demand but young Christoph Duda
that man just played
a three-week period of incredible chess
and it was incredible chess all around
as we take a look at the bracket
this was an epic progression through all
of the GMS you can see how many strong
players were knocked out MBL karyakan
let us say of Carlson buckrow Essa panko
the world's cup is just an insane
tournament and to win it in the way that
Duda did without losing a single game
well
you got to take your hat off
so impressive issue I'm I'm stunned by
duda's performance
sure
it's it's something to behold
and as we see for The Savvy is very
gracious he's smiling but obviously it's
never easy to as you said at a
tournament like this
but um what a tournament it has been so
many ups and downs and upsets everything
anybody could have asked for
and um
there's always this weird Momo in a
tournament like this ends it goes on and
on and on the suspense is building
uh and then it all sort of sort of ends
that's how it happens we're going to go
on a quick break
but please do not go anywhere because we
may or may not have a very special guest
for you so stay
with your seat belts fastened we will be
right back and um
perhaps some awesome stuff is still
ahead so don't go anywhere yet you'll be
right back
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
and we are back as the World's Cup winds
down the last moves have been played
Vichy
um it has been an absolute pleasure and
a great honor to commentate with you and
hear your insights and I I know I speak
for
uh not just myself but the tens of
thousands of fans who really Delight in
hearing all of your incredibly astute
observations and thoughts so I know it's
late for you it's probably dinner time
and um it's been it's been a great
pleasure of issue so
thank you thank you very much
and um
just
just how impressed I am with uh luda's
performance I mean it's one thing to
watch it day by day but it's another
thing to look back and realize he was
undefeated in every single format in
fact
how many type breaks do they have only
one right
well I think only only the one against
Carlson who appears
yeah and maybe one against that video is
such a such a dominant restaurant sorry
yeah but still yes
pretty incredible stuff that is huge
so
um just a phenomenal performance and uh
obviously he'll be an incredible
candidate
absolutely and I do have a question to
ask if him on your behalf uh but for now
Rochelle I'll let you go thanks again
for uh
uh for being here and and for your
commentary it's an honor
thanks and um hopefully you join us
again soon bye Vishing
all right
okay so yeah it really is such a delight
um to have vishy in the commentary Booth
um he offers so many insights and
reminds us uh that this is a great time
to be a chess fan and a great time to be
a consumer of of Chess entertainment um
I certainly can't complain I have
courtside seats so
it is an honor indeed to have five-time
world champion Vichy offering his
insights day in and day out
now don't go anywhere because we might
have yantry stop Duda at the very least
in for an interview and we'll be
updating
you on that um as time goes by and I
might be taking a look at some of the
games so we have one more look at the
bracket here
we see how many hurdles
that is going to enter the common
vocabulary how many hurdles he had to
jump through he had to be grishek in the
tie breaks
of course he had to be Magnus Carlson he
beat the world champion and still that
wasn't enough he had to beat Sergey
kayak and the Challenger of the world
championship title and he beat him too
today's game was a dominant performance
car yakin never loses like this with
black and yet
that's what great players do players who
break into the very least they make
other elite players look like
I don't want to say amateurs but they
make it look easy I think that's the
best way of putting it so
what an incredible performance by Judah
it can't be repeated enough and
obviously he's incredibly humble he's
gracious and he's got all of the
ingredients of of an amazing player as
we take a look at some of the
mouth-watering prizes
will be taking home
100 and a staggering 110 000 minus tax
of course but nonetheless such an
impressive Payday for Duda of course uh
what's worth a lot more what's Priceless
for him is the ticket to candidates to
the candidates tournament uh trust me on
this he is a lot prouder of that uh than
he is of the prize but the prize
certainly does not hurt a cool 80 000
collected by
Sergey karyakanin
Carlson was 60k and Vladimir FedEx at 50
000 a very very nice performance by him
as well even if the conclusion was of
course quite disappointing and I think
we can take a quick look here
um I don't know why I say we but
perhaps the Chad and I we can take a
look at
um
at this final game that dude to play the
clutch win against Sergey kuryakin
which uh which was so smooth so clean in
its execution and
we we saw this this oops uh we saw this
tarash which has become really really
popular lately the c5s cd5 CD4
and immediately things started going a
little bit astray for Sergey
Rook D1 we saw Knight C6 Queen A4 of
course karyakan Drew fedes are very very
confidently in this line so perhaps he
thought that this too would be
um a relatively quick and confident draw
and to me to me personally
uh the Turning Point came here
uh Yvonne and I were expecting you know
Yvonne and I were expecting Beyond
Kristoff to Castle
and the one game that that featured in
this line continued A6 Bishop C6 BC and
black is completely fine here I mean
maybe a tiny Advantage Roy but not more
than that
but due to very fearlessly he goes
Bishop F6 and Knight D5 super concrete
decision it doesn't look that great if
you look at this at first opposite
colored Bishops White's King is as yet
on castled
but it turns out after white castles
that Black's pieces are kind of
scattered all across the board the
bishop is awkward uh black has to waste
the temple improving the position of the
bishop the queen on and actually King E2
my apologies uh of course we were
expecting dude at the castle but instead
he fearlessly goes up to E2 but all of
the observations hold the bishop is
Awkward the queen of B6 is in this place
it's potentially susceptible to attack
we have a seventh rank here that The
Rook can occupy and all of these factors
put together
make it a little bit difficult for black
to defend they make the air
um a little bit thicker and after Bishop
F6 due to calmly doubles Rooks Rook a to
C8 kariakin tries to reinforce the
Knight on C6 in another excellent move
Bishop C4 this is a move that is so easy
to gloss over all right just retrieving
the bishop what's so great about it well
first of all it's prophylactic it stops
night before because of Rook B5 winning
the knife second of all it's Forward
Thinking Duda realizes that that pawn in
F7 that's the pawn he captured to win
the game this is actually in a sense a
move that contributed directly uh to the
fact that he won the game Rook D7
becomes a pretty serious threat perhaps
Sergey could have defended better here
it's always easy to criticize when
you've got the engine turned on the
engine's suggesting weird moves like
Knight d8 or A6 none of them are easy to
play
but still white is a pretty clear Edge
instead Sergey going Queen before
he was banking on this resource and he
thought that after Queen takes Knight
takes well here white is in massive
trouble the bishop on C4 is lost
and if you don't take on B4 it doesn't
seem like you have too many other moves
but in comes Queen B3 trading only on
White's own terms Queen takes B3 the
bishop escapes the X-ray of the rook and
white preserves all of his advantages
here in the end game double Rooks Rook
is inevitably coming to D7
are not so inevitably Sergey said no
you're not coming to D7 but at what cost
now look at how passive this Knight is
in comes the G Pawn Duda keeps his foot
on the gas pedal G4 H6 there were a
couple of junctures here which we
thought Sergey could have defended more
accurately perhaps Bishop C3 was a
better chance you're keeping things a
little bit more open Bishop E7 yielded
the E5 Square
we all thought that Duda would occupy
with the Knight
but instead he occupies it with a rook
one of many many amazing moves that JKD
played in this tournament
it's very concrete it doesn't look great
looks like it falls right into Knight C6
but what does this allow well the Knight
no longer defends D7
Rook on E5 is hanging I don't care in
Comes The Rook Rook D7 look at the
Exquisite quality of play in this game
if 95 and after Knight takes C5 White's
pieces despite being down in exchange in
the end game they overwhelm Black's
badly coordinated passive courses if the
bishop moves then you take on F7 in the
night and everything collapses the
threat of discovered check and mate
forces black to give up the exchange and
white mops up all of the Pawns
that doesn't work Sergey very strong
move Bishop d8
but Rook B5 Duda does not let up he
attacks V7 Knight A5 is
a decisive blunder uh more defensive
chances were probably yielded by B6 but
let's be real I don't think Sergey would
have held this position minister of
defense or not
after Knight A5 perhaps a little bit of
anxiety a little nervousness Rook takes
d8 was a mutual blind spot this would
have ended the game immediately
but Jan Kristoff's Bishop D5 was
definitely good enough as well Rook C7
trying to get this pesky Rook off of D7
but guess what now the bishop on d8 is
poorly defended and Bishop takes F7 is a
classic deflection combination
King G7 Bishop C Bishop Rook C7 Bishop
C7
and after Bishop D5 Bishop b695 right I
think uh Sergey resigned after Bishop D5
not only is white Apple Pawn Black's
entire position collapses here the uh
Pawn on G6 unfortunately he's on a darks
is on a light Square
which means it's very easy to attack
with a combination of Bishop E4 and ih4
the Knight on A5 is out of the game
White's got a massive Pawn majority here
too many threats the position is
completely winning for white
and um Sergey decided not to prolong the
game stopping the clocks congratulating
Jan Kristoff Duda
as the fide World Cup champion so what
an incredible game 30 moves Sergey
karyakin does not
lose a lot of games in 30 moves
and so our two b-day Worlds Cup
champions do it up and you feed a
Women's World Cup champion let's not
forget Alexander kasenic another epic
performance
those two would have a lot to share
about their mentality about their
resolve uh the tenacity and they both
had their unique past but for Duda the
path consisted of some incredible
opening preparation
Exquisite technique
all Chambers are filled every single
match for
JKD as he walks home with over 100k and
a ticket to the candidates
and he's been around for a while I think
it would be unfair to say that this is
this comes all of a sudden he Springs up
out of the woodwork absolutely not
Duda has been over 2700 for a while he's
still in his early 20s though so it's
one of those things where he keeps
accumulating experience he keeps making
improvements
and um at some point it just seems like
something switched on
and he's added a little bit of spice to
his game he's added a little bit of that
Technical incisiveness and perhaps
that's what he needed that's what you
need those small incremental
improvements for pelu past 2750 and
Beyond but let's not take sight of
Magnus Carlson due to beat Magnus
but Magnus nonetheless rebounding with
an Exquisite effort against Vladimir
fedes
and in my opinion today's game against
fedes was excellent but it seemed that
Vladimir was demoralized he didn't get
off on the right foot right out of the
opening
but um
but yesterday's game was was something
else and um I'll just show one more
moment's uh from this from that game
before coming back to JKD and perhaps
his best win of the tournament yesterday
Magnus played at King's Indian against
fedesaf who essayed this H4 line in my
favorite part of yesterday's game just
shows you why the world champion is the
world champion this position
looks like White's got a pretty big
clamp on Black's position nice Center
Pawn on A5 stopping Black from getting
the queen to B6 boom F5 Magnus
fearlessly opening up the position and
after Rook A3 Knight E5 Bishop B3 F4
sacking the pawn
developing Rook takes up for stacking in
exchange this will go straight into some
Soviet style textbooks Bishop H6 Queen
G3 Queen f8 Russian School of Cheers
and look at the paralysis exerted by
Black's Queen Black's Bishop
which control the F4 squared not
allowing white to play up for dislodging
the knight from E5 and Carlos don't know
not to win an excellent genius
positional game there were so many
moments to talk about here this game
will be analyzed and re-analyzed as it
should be
but for young Kristoff dude uh the game
that he himself calls his best game of
the tournament and I think he even
referred to it as the best game of the
year for him
and when you look at the game carefully
you see exactly why he referred to it
that way it was indeed an absolutely
Exquisite effort and I'm talking of
course about his game
with uh vidit Grandmaster from India
vidit is one of the strongest Indian
Grandmasters he's
he's a monster an absolute monster and
the way Duda dismantled him
uh has to be admired by everybody
including video fans and that it's
incredibly nice he's got a very bright
future of head of him as well 27-26 what
a beast what happened in that game well
it was arai Lopez
and again a case of excellent opening
preparation by Duda vet it is one of the
strongest opening theoreticians of the
modern day he doesn't get a lot of
credit for that but having looked at
some of it its game I think his opening
preparation is among the best in the
business
but um they play this Archangel
variation which has been very very
topical skip over the
opening moves it's just important to
point out that this Pawn is not hanging
because Bishop D5 Forks the knights this
is all common theory
and here after Bishop B3 already black
can't grab the pawn because the Knight
on C6 is protected
but Duda enters the super sharp line D5
Bishop E3 DC
Knight F2 Queen E2 clearly opening
preparation
somewhere around this moment vidit
either forgot or he didn't analyze
deeply enough but whatever it was Knight
F2 check was a mistake after Rook F2
there's a mass liquidation lots of
tactics Knight takes C5 comes exposing
an attack against F7 Bishop takes G2
counter Sacrifice by minute and look at
this move King G1 not taking the bishop
either way Queen takes G2 would be bad
on account of Queen H4 check leading to
a perpetual
King takes you to would allow Queen G5
check why is that dangerous because now
already black can take the Knight and
black has that d8 escape score for the
king rendering this check
uh entirely
futile
and um it turned out that after King G1
Queen F6 is forced this leads by force
into an end game
where after Rook takes F7 Bishop F7 King
F7 we have a situation of Knight against
three Pawns looks like it's anybody's
game we've got two past spawns on the
king side three pawns for a knight is a
lot particularly in the end game the way
Duda converted this end game should be
studied by
both beginners and Grandmasters alike it
was Exquisite technique
and I don't have nearly enough time
uh to to go over all the intricacies of
um to go over all the intricacies of
this end game but I'll just show some of
the key points he centralizes his Knight
King G7 the Knight swings around to F2
he's bringing it to D3 into B4 and he's
going right after that pawn on A6 that
pawn doesn't look all that good
uh that pawn doesn't look all that
important and yet that's the pawn Duda
is hunting for Knight D3 Knight before
he doesn't care about any of the other
pawns and Rook day one such patience
Knight takes A6 is a lot worse because
of Rook A2 stopping the pot from behind
but dude that goes Rook A1 excellent
calculation
and after C5 Knight takes A6 B4 Knight
takes B4
ing himself time the Knight leaves A6 to
pave open the pathway for the pawn
and this was the product of excellent
calculation by Kristoff do that A6 BC A7
C2 A8 it looks like black blaze Rook B1
check and black remotes as well and
blacks up three pawns but of course
what's important in these positions it's
who who is to move it's white to move
the king it's wide open and Duda comes
after him like a tie got in its cage
Queen f8 rookie seven there was a lot of
excellent calculation involved here
skewering the queen but rather than just
taking the queen Duda goes for more
Queen B7 ladder Queen A7
and after queen king B5 Queen B8 is
Checkmate on the next move admitted
played King before here
dude I would have gone Queen B6 and it's
the same thing after Rook a seven eight
and what's even more important is after
King A3 which was technically more
resilient
um
the wind here comes in the form of
and let me try to actually remember what
the win is it's it's it's shut here and
then another check on B5
and after King A2 it's Rook to A7 check
forcing Queen A3 black is overextended
white takes on A3
and Place Queen takes B1 and what's the
game what a delightful game
I didn't nearly do it enough Justice um
I skipped over a lot of the subtleties
but I really feel like this was the
turning point and by the way
um you know I will properly express my
appreciation for
for the chat and and the massive
audience at the end but
um this you know the amount of people
watching really makes it magical and uh
I am looking at the chat so if anybody
has questions that you would like to ask
Duda that you would like me to ask Duda
I might consider it if I think the
question is is worthwhile so and even if
I don't get a chance to ask it I think
airing out your questions uh maybe I can
tackle some of them
um well undo his behalf because I
totally know what it's like to win the
World Cup
uh but you know if you if you have any
comments or any particular things that
you observe to do this play
that's some insight which I would love
to hear
as well
who's your favorite streamer and why is
it Bigfoot well
it's um
yeah that leaves a lot of room for
Choice who won third place so third
place was secured by world's formal
Champion my current world champion
uh Magnus Carlson let's take a quick
look at the bracket if you're just
joining today's third place match
between Carlson felicev concluded in
another win for Magnus he wins 2-0 and a
final match is won by John Christopher
who wins a clutch game today there will
be no tie breaks
tomorrow
and um
these tournaments come to an end yeah
there's just the sense of
this is almost gone on for a month
and there were a hundred and usually
there's 128 players to start it was a
weird number this time
um not a catchy number
but
wow 206 men Bigfoot is telling me in 103
women
and that is a just a tremendous amount
of players and using the chess.com
events page
and now I you know I'm not trying to
sell anybody on anything but it is how I
am able to view who was playing in the
tournament one thing that you can do is
you can scroll all the way down
and you can literally see all of the
matchups here
have you forgotten that mommy diara
played in this tournament vladislava
team
Evgeni Beret of our entire voice
um Daniel dubov
Jordan Forest all of these flares also
played in The World's Cup Chris shook
that is who not personally necessarily
but two and I had to overcome all of
them Anton koraboff tomashevsky
so many players over 2700.
it was just a Minefield that you had to
dodge round after round after round
and um this dude I think Magnus regrets
giving him the right so that he doesn't
miss the game with Reddit that was the
actual Turning Point the actual turning
point was due to making his game
and and so therefore he was able to play
and win and
Magnus should have retroactively taken
it back or maybe ask for his money back
at least give me a little bit of a tip
wow
um
what's what an incredible performance
and I'm just going to look over the chat
here to see if anybody has interesting
questions even if I don't answer them I
could just air them out
um and of course I do remember when
Judah won the under 10 world youth in
2008 that is one which I can offer my
insight into when I was playing the
under 14 World youth Chess Championship
in 2008 if I remember correctly Judah
did win
the under 10 section
that year and I did an informal study a
couple of years ago where I checked how
many winners of the world's youth chess
championships under various categories
ended up becoming GMS
and the percentage is actually
staggering the percentages is definitely
well over 50 percent
um and and Duda is of course a a sign of
who these players often become
he was a prodigy he was a GM very very
early and he's just continued going up
from there and another very interesting
step from
a production team here a total of 599
games were played in the open section of
the 2021 fide cup 599 games were
contested and not playing on Sochi
and looking over some of these earlier
games we remember Carolina Fabiano
caruana played in The World's Cup he got
knocked out by Rihanna
and um
I think that's that's one of the things
that makes this tournament the hardest
is precisely the fact that
these are two game matchups
anything can happen in two games I think
somebody made that point besselyn I
think made that point
where no matter how good you are you
might be Fabby playing against 2400 or
you know aronian playing against
somebody or Mama Yara
you make one mistake in one of the games
you lose
um and then you're playing a decent GM
it's pretty easy to fail to win on
demand although we did see a lot of
winning on demand
that's what makes upsets so common in a
tournament like this
and um alireza he succumbed to Java here
sundarov who was absolutely on fire
early in the tournament
of cindarov um siddharov I don't
remember who he lost to but
he went incredibly far
velimir ivich below 2600 he defeated a
bunch of very very strong GMS it looks
like Sundar have lost a pure rune that
was a very very close match
and what a matchup was we had so many
so many interesting games
and and so many interesting matchups
I'm honestly speechless exhausted
speechless we had the Salinas Herrera
brilliancee
um which which also has made the rounds
and we're gonna go on a quick break we
await news of whether we can get John
Kristoff in the studio and as we do that
I'm gonna go on a very short break don't
go anywhere World Cup recap we'll
continue when we come back in just a
couple
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Worlds Cup
and we will have uh Jan Christophe Duda
for you
for an interview at some point
and in the meantime we're just chatting
uh recapping the events of the past
three weeks I mean there are way too
many games to analyze
um and and you know honestly
somebody could just take the world's cup
and
game 300 points just by reviewing uh
some key games from that tournament
and flipping over you know some of these
matchups and yeah using the chess.com
events page
um I'm reminded of so many interesting
moments and so many uh amazing runs from
from this tournament
and let's not forget for example
um he held krasenkov
who
in his late 50s defeated kiril alexenko
he knocked out a very strong gym in
round one
and then he came within a Harris breath
of
of defeating prognanza the young Indian
Talent
um
and he did it by winning on demand in
game two in an absolutely crazy game
this game kind of flew under the radar
um I don't think that I
I don't think that I commentated this
particular round so maybe this game was
maybe this game was was covered
but they got this absolutely crazy
position
uh in a in a slot or in a Queen's Gambit
accepted
and basically light is up technically
white is up an exchange
but black has this
insanely just
just this this Phalanx of pieces and
somehow Crossing up castles you can't
take the queen because of 94 and ic3 we
need to Queen B7
and Crescent got pushed upon maneuvered
as clean around and somehow with some
insane magic tricks he ultimately
liquidated into a winning end game
and unfortunately it does seem like uh
JKD John Kristoff he is absolutely
exhausted he has given all of his energy
and it appears that he prefers to go
back to his room and rest uh and I think
that is the most understandable thing in
the world uh he's already done some
interviews and uh the man the man
deserves some rest and I think we all
we all should appreciate that I
apologize for
uh for leading anybody on but I really
enjoyed this little segment I think it's
always nice to draw conclusions from
such a great tournament
but you know what that means that means
the 2021 free day Worlds Cup has
officially come to an end
it's been a marathon tournament there
have been so many amazing games and I
just wanted to say how much of a
pleasure it has been to compensate most
of this tournament uh with some amazing
legendary co-compensators whether it was
vessel and topolov or huyifan Vichy
Robert Ben I had the best uh code
commentary team in the world and it it
always makes my job easy of course to
the amazing and professional production
team and Bigfoot who was there every
step of the way to make sure
everything's running
uh seamlessly and mainly to all of the
fans there were
over 20 000 day in and day out coming in
from all across the world cheering on
your favorite players and that's what
makes events like these truly magical
twitch YouTube across all platforms we
had massive crowds
and um I really really appreciate it and
I'm sure the players appreciate it and
my co-commentators appreciated the crowd
involvement that's what gives these
tournaments magic and so the time has
come for me to say goodbye one final
time there will be no tie break around
tomorrow because the winner of the World
Cup has been decided and so has the
third place winner and so I say goodbye
to you for the last time you have been
watching the 2021 fide World Cup
congratulations to Young Kristoff Duda
what an amazing tournament it was the
final round is in the books goodbye for
now thank you again to everybody and
have a great rest of the day
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]